I am 50 years old and do you know what I don't want to do on my vacations anymore? Oh probably a few things. I don't want to cram my family into the same one bedroom room and bathroom. I don't want to. No. I don't want us all on top of each other. I want my own bedroom separate from the children, which is why I prefer Airbnb. Because we can all have our space, and then it's like, makes the whole vacation more relaxing. We can go to bed at different times. You know, I can stay up and read,
我今年 50 岁了，你知道我度假时最不想做的事是什么吗？哦，大概有那么几件。我不想把我们一家老小挤在同一个一居室加一间浴室里。我才不想呢。不。我不想大家挤在一块儿。我想要有自己的卧室，跟孩子们分开，这也是为什么我更喜欢爱彼迎。因为我们每个人都能拥有自己的空间，然后这会使整个假期变得更加轻松惬意。我们可以错开时间睡觉。你知道的，我可以熬夜看书，
or more likely these days, I go to bed before everybody else. You know what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have a fridge, you have a kitchen. So I'm not calling up room service constantly and having to pay that fee.
或者现在的真实情况是，我比其他人都要早睡。你知道我有多喜欢爱彼迎吗？什么？零食。你知道我喜欢爱彼迎的什么吗？什么？零食。你有一个冰箱，你有一个厨房。所以我不用老是打电话叫客房服务，还非得付那笔服务费。
I'm just like, hey, we pack snacks. They're in the fridge, go get them. Well, everyone, consider Airbnb for your next adventure. You won't regret making the switch from a traditional hotel. Air Transat presents two friends traveling in Europe for the first time and feeling some pretty big emotions. This coffee is so good. How do they make it so rich and tasty?
我只会觉得，嘿，我们带了零食。它们就在冰箱里，去拿吧。好了，各位，为你们的下一次冒险考虑一下爱彼迎吧。从传统酒店转换过来，你绝对不会后悔。加拿大越洋航空为您呈现两名初次欧洲游并经历剧烈情感波动的挚友。这咖啡太好喝了。他们是怎么把它做得这么香浓美味的？
Those paintings we saw today weren't prints. They were the actual paintings. I have never seen tomatoes like this. How are they so red? With flight deals starting at just $589, it's time for you to see what Europe has to offer. Don't worry, you can handle it. Visit airtransat.com for details, conditions apply.
我们今天看到的那些画可不是印刷品。它们是货真价实的画作。我从来没见过这样的西红柿。它们怎么能这么红？机票优惠只需 589 美元起，是时候去见识一下欧洲的魅力了。别担心，你能应付得来的。访问 airtransat.com 了解详情，条款适用。
Air Transat. Travel moves us. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details,
加拿大越洋航空。旅行触动心灵。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》爱好者的播客。每周我们都会深入探讨《办公室》的世界，带来独家采访、幕后花絮，
and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello there. Hi. We have a really, really fun episode today. I feel like we say that every week, but oh my gosh, if you don't leave with a smile on your face after you listen to this next hour. I don't know what's wrong with you.
以及大量 VFF 的故事。我们是《办公室女士 6.0》。你好呀。嗨。我们今天有一集非常非常有趣的节目。我觉得我们每周都这么说，但是哦天哪，如果你听完接下来这一个小时没有带着微笑离开。我真不知道你脑子哪里有问题。
I don't either. Also we just love our job, so it is a fun thing. It's fun to get to do this. Really fun. Uh huh. I do. I love my job. I feel so fortunate that I love my job too, Ange. Oh, yeah.
我也不知道。另外，我们就是太爱我们的工作了，所以这是一件很有趣的事。做这件事很有趣。真的很有趣。嗯哼。我是。我热爱我的工作。安吉，我感到非常幸运，我也热爱我的工作。哦，是的。
My parents loved their jobs. My mom was a teacher. My dad was a plastics engineer. They loved what they did for a living, and they always told me, we just hope that you get to have a career that you also love. Yeah. And I do. And they-
我父母热爱他们的工作。我妈妈是一名老师。我爸爸是一名塑料工程师。他们热爱他们的谋生方式，他们总是对我说，我们只希望你能拥有一份你也热爱的职业。是的。而我做到了。并且他们——
What a gift, right? They supported me in my pursuit as an actress because they knew, well, that's the thing she loves. That's what makes her heart happy. Yeah. My sister's a teacher. It makes her heart happy. Yeah.
多棒的礼物啊，对吧？他们支持我追求女演员的梦想，因为他们知道，好吧，那是她热爱的事。那是让她的内心感到快乐的事。是的。我姐姐是一名老师。这让她的内心感到快乐。是的。
It's a beautiful thing when that can happen. Yeah. All right, well, listen, you all know that there are still so many people who are on The Office that we have not talked to, that we have wanted to have on the podcast, and today we get to cross one of those names off our list. Yep. Today on Office Ladies 6.0, Timothy Oliphant is in the studio with us. You might know Timothy from his many movies and television roles, including the hugely
当这种事发生时，这是一件美好的事。是的。好吧，听着，你们都知道，在《办公室》里还有好多好多我们没有聊过的人，是我们一直想请到播客上来的，而今天我们终于可以从名单上划掉其中一个名字了。没错。今天在《办公室女士 6.0》节目中，蒂莫西·奥利芬特和我们一起在录音室里。你可能从蒂莫西的许多电影和电视角色中认识他，包括无比
successful shows, Deadwood and Justified. Of course, you know, I loved him in The Mandalorian. And you know what? I did not bring it up on purpose because I didn't want to be a total nerd in front of him. I know, I was already a geek. But I loved him in Mandalorian.
成功的剧集《朽木》和《火线警探》。当然，你知道的，我很喜欢他在《曼达洛人》里的表现。而且你知道吗？我不是故意提起这件事的，因为我不想在他面前表现得像个彻底的书呆子。我知道，我本来就是一个极客。但我太喜欢他在《曼达洛人》里的表现了。
And you know, on The Office, he played Danny Cordray, the top salesman in the Scranton-Wilkesbury area. He was the salesman that Michael Scott eventually hires to work at Dunder Mifflin. Yes, the character of Danny Cordray was in two episodes that aired in the original broadcast, the Sting and Costume Contest. And, Angela, you bring up in our interview
你知道的，在《办公室》里，他饰演了丹尼·科德雷，斯克兰顿-威尔克斯伯里地区的顶级推销员。他就是迈克尔·斯科特最终雇用到邓德米夫林工作的推销员。是的，丹尼·科德雷这个角色在原版播客中播出的两集里出现过，分别是《卧底行动》和《服装大赛》。安吉，你在我们的采访中提到
that he was also in a deleted scene for Michael's last Dundies. Yep. Now, I love the setup to his character. And, Angela, you bring up in our interview that he was also in a deleted scene for Michael's last Dundee's. Yep. Now, I love the setup to his character. In the sting, Jim and Dwight are on a sales call to their client meeting at Frame Select, and they see rival salesperson Danny Cordray
他也曾出现在迈克尔最后的邓迪奖的删减片段中。没错。现在，我真的很喜欢对他的角色的设定。安吉，你在我们的采访中提到他也曾出现在迈克尔最后的邓迪奖的删减片段中。没错。现在，我真的很喜欢对他的角色的设定。在《卧底行动》中，吉姆和德怀特去拜访他们的客户框架精选公司，他们看到了竞争对手推销员丹尼·科德雷
sitting in the lobby. I thought we should hear it. Dwight. Crap. Danny Cordray is the worst. Well, by worst you mean the best. The best salesman ever. He works for Osprey, Paperover, and Throop. Steals more clients from Dunder Mifflin than anyone.
坐在大厅里。我觉得我们应该听听这段。德怀特。废话。丹尼·科德雷是最糟糕的。好吧，你说的最糟糕的意思是最好。史上最好的推销员。他为奥斯珀、造纸过头和特鲁普公司工作。从邓德米夫林挖走的客户比谁都多。
So the situation is the worst. Also, he slept with Pam. No, he didn't. Tell him. Nothing happened. We went on a couple of dates. He slept with Pam. No, he didn't. Tell him. Nothing happened. We went on a couple of dates. He never called me again.
所以这种情况是最糟糕的。还有，他和帕姆睡过。不，他没有。告诉他。什么都没发生。我们约会了几次。他和帕姆睡过。不，他没有。告诉他。什么都没发生。我们约会了几次。他再也没有给我打过电话。
What? He never called you? I thought you said it just fizzled. That's fizzling. I mean, someone has to start the fizzle. Yeah, I thought you started it. No, I liked him. For a couple of days.
什么？他从来没给你打过电话？我以为你说只是不了了之了。那就是不了了之。我的意思是，总得有人开始不了了之吧。对啊，我还以为是你开始的呢。不，我喜欢他。几天。
Four years ago. You know I have a kid with days, four years ago. You know I have a kid with you, right? I just love this. There's so much information and history packed into these little couple of scenes. I know, this was a really fun Jim and Pam runner. We talked more about it, but it was so fun how it kept popping up. Well, I just love that.
四年前。你知道我和你有过一个孩子，四年前。你知道我和你有过一个孩子，对吧？我太喜欢这个了。这些简短的几个场景里塞满了如此多的信息和历史。我知道，这是一个非常有趣的吉姆和帕姆的支线。我们谈论了更多，但它不断地冒出来，真的太有趣了。好吧，我只是觉得——
And Jenna, in rewatching this episode, it was so funny to me how all the Dunder Mifflin employees react to meeting Danny. So we just heard Jim and Dwight, but I also thought you should hear when Michael first sees him and then the whole bullpen. Sam, help me put these clips together. Let's hear it.
而且珍娜，在重温这一集的时候，邓德米夫林的所有员工对见到丹尼的反应对我来说太有趣了。所以我们刚听了吉姆和德怀特的，但我也觉得你们应该听听迈克尔第一次见到他时的反应，然后是整个办公区。山姆，帮我把这些剪辑拼到一起。我们听听看。
Oh no, that's a male model. Oh my God. Janansport Backpacks. 10 or 15 years ago, you were a model for Jansport Backpacks, were you not? Yes. Yeah. What's going on here? I knew it. I remember the one you were like, hey, to Mr. Danny Cordray. He is going to be joining us as our new traveling salesman. Say hello to Danny.
哦不，那是个男模。哦天哪。坚斯波特背包。 10 到 15 年前，你是坚斯波特背包的模特，对吧？是的。 yeah。这到底是怎么回事？我就知道。我记得其中一幅画里你就像是，嘿，致敬丹尼·科德雷先生。他将作为我们新的旅行推销员加入我们。向丹尼打个招呼。
F*** me. Okay, you know what? No. That was a bleep. That was probably standards and practices because Kelly says, you know, the F word. She does. And listen, we've shared this before,
操我。好吧，你知道吗？不。那是一个消音哔声。那可能是标准与实践部门弄的，因为凯莉说了，你知道的，F 开头的脏话。她确实说了。听着，我们之前分享过这个，
but the character named Danny Cordray was inspired by our very own Randy Cordray. And I just love that his name made it on the show. I know. Well, we always love hearing from you all. And several of you wrote in some great observations and comments about the character Danny Cordray, and we wanted to share. Yes. Starting with Ashley S. from Kaysville, Utah, who wrote in to say, I find it funny that Michael has a talking head
但丹尼·科德雷这个角色的灵感来自于我们自己的兰迪·科德雷。我特别喜欢他的名字能出现在节目里。我知道。好吧，我们总是很高兴听到你们大家的来信。你们中的好几个人写信表达了一些关于丹尼·科德雷这个角色的精彩观察和评论，我们想分享一下。是的。从犹他州凯斯维尔的阿什利·S.开始，她写信说，我觉得好笑的是，迈克尔有一段对着镜头的独白，
referencing the killer in Scream 2. One of the murderers is Timothy Oliphant. That murderer is now in the office. Ashley, this cracked me up. You know I'm a horror movie fan. You know I know Scream 2. I held myself back from asking Timothy about Scream 2 in our interview because I didn't want to geek out too much.
提到了《惊声尖叫 2》中的杀手。其中一个凶手就是蒂莫西·奥利芬特。那个凶手现在在办公室里。阿什利，这把我笑死了。你知道我是恐怖片迷。你知道我知道《惊声尖叫 2》。在采访中我克制住自己没有问蒂莫西关于《惊声尖叫 2》的事情，因为我不想显得太书呆子气。
Let's hear this clip of Michael talking about Scream 2. I tried. I tried. I tried to talk to Toby and be his friend. But that is like trying to be friends with an evil snail. I feel like I'm dying inside. I feel like Neve Campbell in Scream 2. She thinks she can go off to college and be happy, and then the murderer comes back, starts
让我们听听迈克尔谈论《惊声尖叫 2》的这段音频。我试过了。我试过了。我试着和托比说话并和他做朋友。但这就像是尝试和一只邪恶的蜗枝交朋友。我觉得我在内心深处死去。我觉得自己就像《惊声尖叫 2》里的内芙·坎贝尔。她以为自己可以去上大学然后过得幸福快乐，接着凶手回来了，开始
killing off all of her friends. Learned a lot of lessons from that movie. comes back, starts killing off all of her friends. Learned a lot of lessons from that movie. This is just one of them. Mm-hmm. There's more. There's more lessons than Scream 2. Well, uh, Scream 2 was early in Timothy's career. I mean, he is playing a college student. He is so good in it. He is such a great villain. Like he always often is playing kind of like the nicer guys. The hero guy. But always with
杀光她所有的朋友。从那部电影里学到了很多教训。回来了，开始杀光她所有的朋友。从那部电影里学到了很多教训。这只是其中之一。嗯哼。还有呢。还有比《惊声尖叫 2》更多的教训。好吧，呃，《惊声尖叫 2》是在蒂莫西职业生涯的早期。我的意思是，他扮演的是个大学生。他在里面演得太好了。他真是一个绝佳的反派。就像他经常扮演的那样，有点像那种比较好的人。英雄型人物。但总是带着
a little darkness. It's interesting we talked to him about it. Good catch Ashley. I loved it. Well we also got this fun catch from Carly F. and Prospect Heights Illinois. She said her and her husband were watching Justified and they realized that Dave Keckner had a few episodes. She said they loved that Timothy and Dave Keckner had a few episodes together, even though they didn't have any together on the office, but they were both traveling salesmen. They also found it ironic that their joint episodes
一丝黑暗。我们能和他聊聊这个挺有意思的。干得漂亮，阿什利。我太喜欢了。好吧，我们还收到了来自伊利诺伊州展望Heights的卡莉·F.的一个有趣的发现。她说她和她丈夫在看《火线警探》，他们发现戴夫·凯克纳客串了几集。她说他们很喜欢蒂莫西和戴夫·凯克纳一起演了好几集，尽管他们在《办公室》里没有对手戏，但他们都是旅行推销员。他们还觉得具有讽刺意味的是，他们在《火线警探》中共同出演的剧集
in Justified both take place in Florida, which is where Todd Packer ends up at the end of The Office. Oh my gosh! This is like a monk crossover, but it's a Justified The Office crossover. I just started watching Justified. It's really good. It's so good, I have not gotten to Dave Kechner yet.
都发生在佛罗里达州，而这也是托德·帕克在《办公室》结局时最终去的地方。哦天哪！这就像是一个蒙克跨界剧，但它是《火线警探》和《办公室》的跨界。我刚开始看《火线警探》。真的很好看。太好看了，我还没看到戴夫·凯克纳出场呢。
I haven't either, I just started watching it too. Well everyone, thank you so much for writing in. We used a lot of your questions in our interview with Timothy as well. And you know, we're so excited to reunite with him and this really all came about, Jenna, because you ran into him last year. Yes, we were at a mutual friend's birthday party
我也没看到，我也才刚开始看呢。好吧，各位，非常感谢你们写信来。我们在对蒂莫西的采访中也用了你们的好多问题。而且你知道的，我们很高兴能与他重聚，这一切其实都是因为，珍娜，你去年偶遇了他。对，我们在一个共同朋友的生日派对上，
and I asked him if he would come on the podcast. He was so lovely. He said, of course. We did this interview right before our holiday break and it was just such a great way to end the year. It really was. He's so charming and he hung out with us for over an hour. We talked to him about his time on the office
我问他愿不愿意来上播客。他太友善了。他说，当然。我们在假期前的最后关头完成了这次采访，这真的是为这一年画上句号的绝佳方式。确实如此。他太有魅力了，而且陪了我们一个多小时。我们和他聊了他在《办公室》的时光
and so many other things. So let's take a short break. And when we come back, our interview with Timothy Oliphant. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Every January is a time when I feel like we all reflect. You know, you can really do it any time of the year, but I think, you know, you do feel that reset. You do.
以及许多其他事情。所以我们先休息一会儿。回来后，就是我们对蒂莫西·奥利芬特的采访。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。每年一月都是我觉得我们所有人都会反思的时候。你知道的，你其实一年中的任何时候都可以这样做，但我认为，你知道的，你确实会感觉到那种重置。确实。
It's like you have 365 blank pages ahead of you just waiting to be filled and you can decide how to do that. I'm so poetic Angela. Oh really? Thanks. 365 blank pages. Well I might have had some help. All right. Well I'm going with your book metaphor. Okay. You could think of therapy as your editorial partner, helping you to write these new chapters and create the meaningful story that you deserve to live. How do you like that? I really like it a lot. BetterHelp is fully online
这就好像你面前有 365 张空白页，正等待着被填满，而你可以决定如何去做。我是多么富有诗意啊，安吉。哦，真的吗？谢谢。 365 张空白页。好吧，我可能得到了一些帮助。好吧。那我可要顺着你的书本隐喻往下说了。好吧。你可以把心理咨询视为你的编辑合伙人，帮助你书写这些新篇章，并创造出你理应拥有的有意义的人生故事。你觉得这个怎么样？我真的很喜欢。 BetterHelp 完全是在线的，
and making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. It has a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. And you can switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Write your story with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's Better Help, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. at salesforce.com. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today.
让心理咨询变得实惠且便捷，服务全球超过 500 万人。它拥有一个由 3 万多名持有资质的治疗师组成的多元化网络，涵盖广泛的专业领域。而且你可以随时更换治疗师，无需支付额外费用。用 BetterHelp 书写你的人生故事。今天就访问 betterhelp.com 斜杠 office ladies，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是 Better Help，H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。在 salesforce.com。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。
Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today.
今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。
Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. Call us today. world what AI was meant to be. Let's create the agent-first future together. Head to salesforce.com slash careers to learn more. Miller Lite. The light beer brewed for people who love the taste of beer and the perfect pairing for your game time. When Miller Lite set out to brew a light beer, they had to choose great taste or 90 calories per can.
今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。今天给我们打电话。向世界展示 AI 本该有的样子。让我们一起创造以代理为先的未来。前往 salesforce.com 斜杠 careers 了解更多信息。美乐淡啤。专为热爱啤酒口感的人酿造的淡啤，是您比赛时光的完美绝配。当美乐淡啤着手酿造一款淡啤时，他们必须在极佳口感或每罐 90 卡路里之间做出选择。
They chose both because they knew the best part of beer is the beer. Your game time tastes like Miller time. Learn more at MillerLite.ca. Must be legal drinking age. My goodness. Timothy, all of going? Good. Oh my gosh, how cool to see you sitting across from us when you've got a scarf on. Well, it's the season. It is the season, yeah.
他们两样都选了，因为他们知道啤酒最棒的部分就是啤酒本身。你的比赛时光尝起来就像美乐时光。在 MillerLite.ca 了解更多信息。必须达到法定饮酒年龄。我的天啊。蒂莫西，一切都好吗？挺好的。哦天哪，看到你戴着围巾坐在我们对面，感觉太酷了。嗯，当季嘛。确实是当季，是的。
How are you doing? We're good. How are the ladies? The ladies are good. How long have the ladies been in this building? It didn't start here. No. No, no, no.
你最近怎么样？我们很好。女士们怎么样？女士们挺好的。女士们在这个大楼里待多久了？不是从这里开始的。没有。不，不，不。
I like that. I'm going to try to get more of those moments right there. More in unison. Answers. We started at Earwulf, which was this great little space. And then Sirius bought Earwulf and then we ended up renting this little space, which was cute, but like we had a we had like a shower curtain that like separated us from other from Sam and Cassie in the booth. It was sweet. It was cute. But now we're with the folks at Odyssey and we got real fancy building. And that's this is their floor.
我喜欢这样。我要试着多捕捉一些那样的时刻。更有默契的回答。我们从 Earwulf 开始的，那是很棒的小空间。然后 Sirius 收购了 Earwulf，接着我们租下了这个小空间，挺可爱的，不过我们有个像浴帘一样的东西，把我们跟山姆和卡西隔在录音间外面。挺温馨的。很可爱。但现在我们和 Odyssey 的伙伴们在一起了，我们有了真正高档的大楼。这就是他们的楼层。
This is their building. Yeah. This is their nook. And this space is your space? Yeah. Way to go. Right? I'll get you two. Yeah. That's really good. Pretty good.
这是他们的建筑。是的。这是他们的角落。这个空间是你们的空间？是的。真了不起。对吧？我给你们俩点个赞。对。真的很好。挺不错的。
We're doing all right. Yeah, it's very. Look, we have these doohickeys too. I know, the whole thing is- It says office ladies on the microphone. Pretty swanky. Yeah. Who would have thunk?
我们过得还行。是的，非常。看，我们也有这些小玩意。我知道，整件事——麦克风上写着办公室女士。挺时髦的。对啊。谁能想到呢？
I know, right? Just two gals chatting about a show they were on. Chatting, just chatting about. Here in Hollywood, there's a walk of, there's the stars? Yeah, the walk of fame. We don't have one. Wait, do you have a star? No, I don't have a star.
我懂，对吧？就两个唠嗑她们演过的节目的女孩。唠嗑，就是唠嗑。在好莱坞这里，有一条星光大道，有那些星星？对，星光大道。我们没有。等等，你有一颗星吗？不，我没有星星。
I don't have a star. You know, every now and then you have these moments, you're like, yeah, you're in showbiz. That's right. Little razzle dazzle. I do feel a little showbiz-y when I come here, because I'm coming into the heart of Hollywood. You know, when I first moved to I'm coming into the heart of Hollywood.
我没有星星。你知道的，时不时地你会有这种时刻，你会觉得，没错，你在演艺圈。没错了。带点浮华耀眼的感觉。我来这里时确实觉得自己有点身处演艺圈的感觉，因为我要走进好莱坞的心脏地带。你知道的，当我刚搬到——我正在走进好莱坞的心脏地带。
You know, when I first moved to LA, I lived in West Hollywood. And I went by all this stuff all the time. But I moved out. I'm not in West Hollywood anymore. You left. Yeah. All right, I'm jumping in.
你知道的，当我刚搬到洛杉矶时，我住在西好莱坞。我经常路过所有这些地方。但我搬走了。我不在西好莱坞了。你离开了。对。好吧，我要切入正题了。
Okay, jumping in. Ready? All right. Okay, here we go. So listen, we usually start with the same question. We usually ask people, how did you get- They offered it to me. Your job in the office, you already know, but I was going to start with it. You know, first time, I was having first time call it last, anyway, I'm like, yeah, I've listened,
好的，切入正题。准备好了吗？好的。好吧，我们开始吧。所以听着，我们通常以同一个问题开始。我们通常问别人，你是怎么得到的——他们主动找我的。你在办公室的工作，你已经知道了，但我本来打算从这个开始的。你知道，第一次，我本来想把第一次通话留到最后，总之，我说，好吧，我听过了，
I got it. I got no story for you other than they offer it to me and I said yes. Wait, can we just go on record that Timothy listens to office ladies? Yeah. Thank you. For sure. Let's go. Wow. Yeah. They offered it to you? You guys are huge.
我懂了。我没有什么故事好讲给你们听的，除了他们主动找到了我，然后我答应了。等等，我们可以记录在案，说蒂莫西会听《办公室女士》吗？是的。谢谢。当然。开始吧。哇。是的。他们主动找你的？你们节目太火了。
They gave you the office because people are listening. You know that, right? I love it. Well, I was actually gonna start with another question, which was how'd you get your start in showbiz? Like when in your life did you realize that you wanted to be an actor? I articulated it sometime in my early 20s. Okay, you said it out loud. Yes. Yeah. Yes. That's a big
他们把办公室的工作交给你，因为大家都在听。你知道这个的，对吧？我喜欢这样。好吧，我其实打算从另一个问题开始，那就是你是怎么开始进入演艺圈的？就像你生命中的什么时候，你意识到你想成为一名演员的？我在 20 岁出头的某个时候把它明确表达出来了。好吧，你把它大声说出来了。是的。对。是的。不过这可是一件
deal though because you usually don't think of it. My wife, I remember, I know it, I may not have articulated it. I don't, well let me say this. I do remember articulating it to my wife. We got married at 22, I just had turned 23. And she, I do know that her response was, you've never mentioned this before. So, I saw that I wanna, so first started talking about it like 22 around there, Yeah. What inspired that? Had you been in a college production or what?
大事，因为你通常不会去想它。我记得我妻子，我懂的，我可能没有明确表达出来。我不知道，好吧，让我这么说吧。我确实记得向我妻子明确表达过。我们 22 岁结婚，我刚满 23 岁。而她，我确实知道她的反应是，你以前从未提过这个。所以，我看到我想，所以第一次谈论它大约是在 22 岁左右，是的。是什么激发了这种想法？你参加过大学话剧团还是什么的？
Nothing. Nothing. Now, when I was younger, I do remember thinking, oh, I'd love to do that. I remember thinking comedy, stand-up comedy, I remember thinking that. And my mom said, you don't want to do that. Those people are all on drugs and they're divorced and they're on drugs. And then at a certain point I was like, Mom, you're divorced. You're halfway there. You might as well be in showbiz. So yeah, never done it before. I'd never done it. Wow. And so where do you go from there? So you're like-
什么都没有。什么都没有。不过，当我更年轻的时候，我确实记得自己想过，哦，我很想做那个。我记得我想过喜剧，单口喜剧，我记得我想过这个。我妈妈说，你才不想做那个呢。那些人全都在吸毒，而且他们离婚了，他们都在吸毒。然后到了某个时候，我就说，妈，你都离婚了。你已经进行了一半了。你索性也进演艺圈算了。所以，是的，以前从来没做过。我从来没做过。哇。那从那以后你怎么办？所以你就像——
Grew up in Modesto, by the way. Grew up in Modesto. We got a fan question about that. We asked people to write in, and someone actually said, Megan G from Albany said, my husband and I lived in Modesto, California. What does Timothy remember about growing up there? Folks are really proud of him out there.
顺便说一句，在莫德斯托长大。在莫德斯托长大。我们为此收到过一个粉丝的问题。我们让大家写信进来，其中有人说，来自奥尔巴尼的梅根·G 说，我和我丈夫住在加利福尼亚州的莫德斯托。蒂莫西对在那里长大有什么记忆吗？那里的人们为他感到非常自豪呢。
Aw. Oh, that's very kind. I mean, I don't, I mean, I still, my mom lives in Modesto. I still go to Modesto. I was in Modesto just in October. So, yeah. My favorite bread maker is in Modesto, Bonnie O'Hara.
哦。哦，这太善良了。我的意思是，我并不，我的意思是，我依然，我妈妈住在莫德斯托。我还是会去莫德斯托。我十月份刚去过莫德斯托。所以，是的。我最喜欢的面包师在莫德斯托，邦妮·奥哈拉。
She has a home bakery, fresh breads and cookies and stuff. Wait. That might be my, wait aads and cookies and stuff. Wait. That might be my, wait a minute. What? Wait, wait. Well, that can't be right. Is her name Bonnie? I'm forgetting a name.
她开了一家家庭面包坊，卖新鲜面包和曲奇之类的东西。等等。那可能就是我的，等等，卖面包和曲奇之类的东西。等等。那可能就是我的，等等。什么？等等，等等。好吧，那不可能对。她叫邦妮吗？我记不清名字了。
But the woman who used to live across from my street, from my mother, had made in her garage, she had a home bakery. Yeah. And she was doing really well. Is that Bonnie? I don't know. Bonnie was your neighbor?
但是那个以前住在我家街对面、我母亲家对面的女人，在她的车库里做过，她开了一家家庭面包坊。是的。而且她生意做得很好。那是邦妮吗？我不知道。邦妮是你的邻居？
What's her? Bonnie O'Hara. And do we need a moment to Google? She wrote a cookbook. No, I'm looking at my contacts. No, I don't think it's her. I go. Okay, she wrote a cookbook.
她叫什么？邦妮·奥哈拉。我们需要花点时间谷歌一下吗？她写过一本食谱。不，我在看我的联系人。不，我觉得不是她。我走。好吧，她写过一本食谱。
She's your favorite. Yeah. Bread Making for Beginners. And I bought her cookbook. I started making bread thanks to her. But she has got a whole business in her little home kitchen and she sells bread subscriptions. No, for a second there. For a second there, I don't think. Bonnie, if I do know you, I'm really
她是你的最爱。Yeah。初学者做面包。我买过她的食谱。多亏了她，我才开始做面包。但她在她的小厨房里做成了整整一桩生意，她还出售面包订阅。不，刚才有一秒钟。刚才有一秒钟，我觉得不是。邦妮，如果我真的认识你，我真的很
sorry because it's been a minute. But listen, if it's not Bonnie, the takeaway is Modesto is the mecca for bread making. Yeah. Good bread there. Awesome good bread. Yeah. I just finished a job in Finland and the AD made the best bread. Homemade? Homemade bread.
抱歉，因为已经过去好一会儿了。但听着，如果不是邦妮，我们要得到的结论是，莫德斯托是做面包的麦加圣地。是的。那里有好面包。好得不得了的面包。是的。我刚在芬兰完成了一份工作，那里的副导演做出了最棒的面包。自制的？自制面包。
They're big on their bread there. Very healthy good breads in Finland. I guess Europe just has great bread in general. They do. People say like, oh, if you don't want gluten, don't worry about it so much there in Europe. Anyway, I don't understand it. And as a wrap, Giffey gave me the recipe. No kidding. He gave me a little notebook and a handwritten recipe. Tried to convert it from metric. And we haven't made it yet, but that's the plan this holiday. We're going to make the bread. Auntie, Auntie's bread.
他们那里的人很注重面包。芬兰有非常健康美味的面包。我猜欧洲整体上就有很棒的面包。确实如此。人们常说，哦，如果你不想吃麸质，在欧洲就不用太担心这个。总之，我不懂。作为杀青礼物，吉菲给了我食谱。不是开玩笑的。他给了我一个小笔记本和手写的食谱。试着把它从公制转换过来。我们还没做过，但那是这个假期的计划。我们要烤面包。阿蒂，阿蒂的面包。
I love that. First day of D. I'm a bread enthusiast. Okay. Jenna used to bring in like her yeast, like in the bowl, right? Is that what it's called? Yeah, you gave it a name? Well, I would bring in my dough.
我太喜欢了。第一天。我是一个面包爱好者。好的。珍娜以前总是把酵母带过来，就像放在碗里那样，对吧？是这么叫的吗？对，你给它取了个名字？好吧，我会把我的面团带过来。
Angela, ask her. My yeast gets a name, right? My starter, my starter's name was Goldie. Your starter gets... Did you know? What? No. How long have you two known each other? Am I here to bring you together? Bring you closer?
安吉，问问她。我的酵母有个名字，对吧？我的面头，我的面头的名字叫戈尔迪。你的面头有……你知道吗？什么？不知道。你们俩认识多久了？我是来把你们撮合到一起的吗？让你们更亲近？
I didn't know your starter had a name. Yes, its name was Goldie. Goldie. Because you have to feed it every day and I said it's like taking care of a goldfish, so I named it Goldie. How did you know that? You know you're this close to having a second podcast. You're gonna be my replacement.
我不知道你的面头有名字。是的，它的名字叫戈尔迪。戈尔迪。因为你必须每天喂它，我说这就像照顾一条金鱼，所以我给它取名叫戈尔迪。你是怎么知道的？你知道你离拥有第二个播客只有这么一点距离了吗？你要成我的替代者了。
All about Fred. With Timothy and Jenna. You laugh, but. It could happen. Oh my God, for sure it could happen. Okay, back to your career. This is a show, you've built a monster show here all based on one half hour comedy.
全关于面包。由蒂莫西和珍娜主持。你笑了，但。这真有可能。哦天哪，绝对有可能。好吧，回到你的职业生涯。这是一个节目，你在这里打造了一个现象级的节目，全都是基于一个半小时的喜剧。
Yeah. Bread. It's bigger. It's huge. It's bigger than the office. I mean, it's huge. People love the office. People really love bread.
是的。面包。它更宏大。它超大。它比《办公室》还要大。我的意思是，这很大。人们热爱《办公室》。人们真的很爱面包。
I mean, it's a big deal. It's a big deal. I'm just saying. I would bet. What do you mean, you're a big deal. It's a big deal. I'm just saying. I would bet. What are you in here, twice a week? Most people. How many days a week are you in here?
我的意思是，这是件大事。这是件大事。我只是说说。我敢打赌。你这是什么意思，你是个大人物。这是件大事。我只是说说。我敢打赌。你在这儿干嘛呢，一周来两次？大多数人。你一周来几天？
One day. Are you wanting to risk space? Once a week? Exactly, for the bread podcast? Yeah. Come on. Timothy's gonna be in here on Tuesdays, guys. We'll bring you on.
一天。你想冒险占用空间吗？一周一次？没错，为了面包播客？得了吧。蒂莫西周二会来这儿，伙计们。我们会把你请来的。
We have a network now. We do, we have a network. You can have a bread podcast on our network if you want it. You have a network? Yes, the Office Ladies Network. What the? What the hell? Yeah.
我们现在有网络平台了。对，我们有网络平台。如果你想要的话，你可以在我们的网络平台上做一个面包播客。你们有网络平台？是的，办公室女士网络。什么鬼？搞什么鬼？是的。
God damn it, I've miss-met my whole show business. Listen, Bread with Timothy. It could happen. It could. All right, what's our next question? Oh wait, I'll do this. Theme song by Bread. By Bread.
该死，我把我的整个演艺生涯都错过了。听着，和蒂莫西一起做面包。这完全可能。绝对可以。好吧，我们的下一个问题是什么？哦等等，我要做这个。主题曲由 Bread 乐队演唱。由 Bread 乐队。
You know the band? Yes. There you go. Okay, wait. It writes itself. It does. It really does. It's right there.
你知道这个乐队吗？知道。这就对了。好吧，等等。这简直不言自明。确实如此。就在那儿。
We were gonna ask you next. I haven't said anything I remember about Modesto, by the way. Yeah, what is besides the bread? What is your favorite place to eat Modesto? Like what's your, like I know Archer City, Texas. I go to Mearns for a cheeseburger. Oh, wow. You know, I mean, the places I've been going to lately
我们本来想接着问你的。顺便说一句，我还没说任何我记得的关于莫德斯托的事。是的，除了面包之外还有什么？你在莫德斯托最喜欢去哪里吃？比如你的，就像我知道德克萨斯州阿彻城一样。我去默恩斯吃芝士汉堡。哦，哇。你知道的，我的意思是，我最近常去的地方
are not places I went to growing up. Modesto, I mean, growing up when I think of like, where'd you go to eat when you were growing up? I mean, we're like, we went to Arby's and we went to, you know, like Taco Bell, tacos, you know, that kind of thing. It was kind of a fast food joint. There was an incredible, I think it's still there, Mexican joint on the way out to Oakdale. Oh, I can't remember it. God, I'm terrible. But that would be like, that was great to go out there. And I'm pretty sure that's still there.
并不是我从小去的地方。莫德斯托，我的意思是，长大后当我想到，你小时候去哪里吃饭？我的意思是，我们就像，我们去阿比斯汉堡，我们去，你知道的，像塔可钟，塔可，你知道，那种地方。那有点像快餐店。有一个不可思议的，我想它现在还在，在去奥克代尔的路上有一家墨西哥餐馆。哦，我想不起来了。天哪，我太糟糕了。但那会像，去那儿吃感觉太棒了。而且我很确信它现在还在。
Mexican food place on the way to Oakdale. I don't sound like, I've really drifted far from my roots. Modesto's Golden Sun. I really have. Cause we didn't really go out to, it's not a go out to dinner tune. I know. You know? Yeah.
去奥克代尔路上的墨西哥餐馆。听起来我真的离我的根基越来越远了。莫德斯托的金色太阳。我真的是。因为我们真的不怎么出去吃，这不是一个出去吃正餐的小镇。我知道。你知道吗？是的。
Like my memories of food in terms of, it's like going to get Winchell's on Sunday morning, or getting donuts or something. Yeah. Oh, that's good though. I don't remember like foodie places. There's a little bit of that now, because almost the whole country's got into food.
就像我对食物的记忆，那种感觉就像星期天早上出去买温切尔甜甜圈，或者买甜甜圈什么的。是的。哦，那也挺好的。我不记得有什么美食店。现在多多少少有一点了，因为几乎整个国家都开始追求美食了。
Right. Foodie places. Fancy foodies. Yeah. So yeah, no, my childhood memories are just, you know, it was all about just roaming around. We, you know, canals and orchards and all that. That's the end of that story. Cake parties in the orchard, you know what I mean?
对。美食店。高档美食家。是的。所以，是的，不，我的童年记忆只是，你知道的，全都是四处瞎逛。我们，你知道的，运河、果园和所有这些。那个故事就到此为止。在果园里开蛋糕派对，你知道我的意思吗？
In the canal. Yeah. That was the teenage years times. Yeah. Yeah. We had pasture parties when I moved back to the States. But I read that you were a swimmer. Swam.
在运河里。是的。那是少男少女时代的时光。是的。是的。当我搬回美国时，我们在牧场开过派对。但我读到过你是个游泳运动员。游过泳。
I grew up next to, we grew up next door to a place which is still there called, it was at the time called the Modesto Swim and Racket Club. It was literally, we had an old farmhouse, we had a field and a barn, horse, chickens and stuff that. And we could just walk through that over to the racket club. And so my brothers and I all we just were there all the time just running around. You know, it was a walk to school neighborhood and yeah so. That sounds really good to me right now.
我是在旁边长大的，我们在一处至今仍在的地方隔壁长大，当时叫莫德斯托游泳与球拍俱乐部。真的，我们有一栋老旧的农舍，我们有一块田地和一座谷仓，养着马、鸡之类的东西。我们可以直接穿过那个地方走到球拍俱乐部。所以我和我的兄弟们我们一直都在那儿到处乱跑。你知道的，那是一个步行就能到学校的街区，所以，是的。这听起来现在对我有极大的吸引力。
Yeah, so I swam and we all swam and played tennis. My brother and I, by the way, we're hosting a charity tomorrow, tennis charity. My brother and I, we've never done it before, first annual, OLE, it's what we're calling it, the OLE. We're raising money for this really great place called the Center for Reflective Communities. It deals with teen and young adult mental health. And so if people want to go on there, they can hit the little plus sign and donate. And where it says subject, you can put in our thing, Play For Good, the OLE, Play For Good and donate money. And God bless you, because they do wonderful work for, Lord knows the young people need some help these days.
是的，所以我游过泳，我们都游过泳，还打网球。我和我兄弟，顺便说一句，我们明天要主持一个慈善活动，网球慈善赛。我和我兄弟，我们以前从没做过，第一届年度赛事，OLE，这就是我们对它的称呼，The OLE。我们正在为一个名为“反思社区中心”的非常棒的地方筹集资金。它关注青少年和年轻成年的心理健康。所以如果人们想去那里，他们可以点击那个加号进行捐赠。在主题栏里，你可以填入我们的项目，为美好而战，The OLE，为美好而战并捐款。上帝保佑你们，因为他们为孩子们做了了不起的工作，上帝知道现在的年轻人确实需要一些帮助。
Well, we'll share that. We'll put it in our Instagram stories with a swipe up and I'll show up with my racket. Oh, let's go. Okay. Bring it. We're playing a Dingles. I love Dingles. Okay, we're playing Dingles and we've got like,
好吧，我们会分享这个。我们会把它发到我们的 Instagram 快拍里，带上上滑链接，我会带着我的球拍出现。哦，走吧。好的。带上它。我们要打双打。我喜欢双打。好的，我们在打双打，而且我们有，
I think there's like 16 or 17 players that are all coming and donating like 500 bucks to play. And then like 16, 17 pros. Oh gosh, so maybe. But still come out and hit some balls. You can hit with some pros. Wait, are you playing? I'm playing.
我觉得大约有 16 或 17 名球员都会来，并且每人捐 500 美元来打球。然后大约有 16、17 名职业选手。哦天哪，所以也许。但还是出来击击球吧。你可以和一些职业选手过招。等等，你要打吗？我要打。
Dingles is so fun. You can come out and play a little bit, hit with some of the pros, and you can only say, okay, it's too much, I don't wanna play anymore, and just hang out and there's alcohol. Great. Dingles is, you have to hit cross court.
双打太好玩了。你可以出来玩一会儿，和一些职业选手过招，如果你觉得，好吧，太多了，我不想玩了，随时可以停下来，去旁边闲逛，那里还有酒精饮料。太棒了。双打的规则是，你必须打对角线。
So like I have to hit cross court, and then the person next to me hits cross court. And then the first person that misses, you can only hit cross court. So like I have to hit cross court and then the person next to me hits cross court. And then the first person that misses, you can only do cross court. And when you miss you yell, dingles. And then the other ball that's active becomes a free ball for the whole court. But what happens to me is the minute someone yells dingles,
所以就像我必须打对角线，然后我旁边的人必须打对角线。然后第一个失误的人，你只能打对角线。所以就像我必须打对角线，然后我旁边的人必须打对角线。然后第一个失误的人，你只能打对角线。当你失误时，你得大喊，双打。然后另一个处于活动状态的球就会成为整个球场都可以争夺的自由球。但发生在我身上的情况是，只要有人大喊双打，
I like, I freeze. Cause I'm like, what happened? And then the ball goes moving past me. I'm like, ah. Cause like, imagine someone next to you yelling dingles really loud. Dang off! Wouldn't that make you?
我就会，我就会僵住。因为我在想，发生了什么？然后球就从我旁边飞过去了。我就想，啊。因为，想象一下你旁边有人很大声地喊着双打。Dang off!难道这不会让你？
It would, yeah. It did right now. I could see it on her face. I froze. I stopped talking. As soon as you guys started saying dingles, I haven't said a word. We're doing it tomorrow.
会的，是的。刚才确实让我这样了。我能从她的脸上看出来。我僵住了。我不说话了。从你们开始说双打的那一秒起，我一句话都没说。我们明天就要去打这个了。
Yay! Yeah. Okay. There we go. Now let's see. Okay, back to The Office. Had you seen the show before? Were you a fan of it?
耶！是的。好吧。就是这样。现在让我们看看。好吧，回到《办公室》。你之前看过这个节目吗？你是它的粉丝吗？
Did you know anyone on The Office? Oh, yeah. Yeah. I'd seen both versions. Did I know anyone? I knew Rain. Oh, yeah. Rain Wilson, when I first started acting in New York, he was my understudy in a play.
你认识《办公室》里的任何人吗？哦，是的。是的。两个版本我都看过。我认识谁吗？我认识雷恩。哦，是的。雷恩·威尔逊，当我刚开始在纽约演戏时，他在一出戏里是我的候补演员。
What was the play? Pretty sure that's true. It was called The Monogamous at Playwrights Horizons. By the way, I'm gonna go see Rain's play Friday. Waiting for Godot. Saturday, closing night. I'm gonna go see Waiting for Godot on Saturday. I saw it, he's great in it.
那是哪出戏？我很确定是真的。那部戏叫《一夫一妻制》，在 Playwrights Horizons 上演。顺便说一句，我星期五要去看雷恩的戏。《戈多等待》。星期六，闭幕之夜。我星期六要去看《戈多等待》。我看过，他在里面演得真棒。
Yeah, I can't wait. He's really good. I have a question from a fan. Let's go. It's Amit R. from Edmonton, Alberta, who wants to know on The Office, what was hardest to get used to, the improvising in scenes or learning to see the camera as a separate character?
是的，我等不及了。他真的很棒。我有一个粉丝的问题。我们来吧。来自阿尔伯塔省埃德蒙顿的阿米特·R.，他想知道在《办公室》里，最难适应的是什么，是场景中的即兴表演，还是学会把摄像机当作一个独立的角色的？
Take us back. You're very great, like right out of the gate at like clocking the camera. Yeah. Because some people that threw them off, but you, we watched you look at the camera. I appreciate hearing that. I was about to answer that question with the question, which was, I don't remember, did I look at the camera?
带我们回顾一下。你非常厉害，一上手就能精准地捕捉到摄像机的位置。是的。因为有些人会被这一点搞糊涂，但你，我们看着你看着摄像机。听到这个我很高兴。我正要用一个问题来回答这个问题，那就是，我不记得了，我有看过摄像机吗？
What? Yes. It's all very vague, foggy to me, what I, my experience. I don't remember. You do, you clog a camera. Am I on one episode or multiple episodes? You're on two episodes. I'm on two episodes. Two and then you have a cameo and Michael's.
什么？有。这一切对我来说都很模糊，我的经历。我不记得了。你确实，你捕捉到了摄像机。我是在一集里还是多集里？你在两集里。我是在两集里。两集，然后你在迈克尔的剧集里有个客串。
I hope that doesn't sound pretentious, I just don't remember. No, no, it's fine. You're in two episodes and then you have a little cameo for Michael's Last Dundee's where Michael sends the camera crew, because Danny Cordray wins hottest in the office. And it's in deleted
我希望这听起来不自命不凡，我只是真的记不清了。不，不，这很好。你在两集里，然后你在迈克尔最后的邓迪奖里有一个小客串，迈克尔派出了摄像团队，因为丹尼·科德雷赢得了办公室最性感奖。它在删减
scenes and I'm pretty sure it'll end up in the super fan episodes too. But yeah, so you're you do win a deleted scene in another episode. Yes. Michael's last two episodes and then you got deleted from a third, but you'll probably be added back. Oh, and what's that scene? You've won hottest in the but I didn't show up for that. You didn't. And so you come on-
片段中，我很确信它最终也会出现在超级粉丝版剧集里。但是的，所以在另一集里你确实赢得了一个删减片段。是的。迈克尔最后两集的客串，然后你从第三集里被删掉了，但你可能会被加回去。哦，那是哪个场景？你赢得了办公室最性感，但我没有去现场。你没有。所以你出场——
So how am I in it? Oh, they put me on the screen? Michael has a TV screen. Yeah. And your character says, yeah, I said I couldn't be there, but Michael sent out a camera crew to my house. Oh, so I shot that. You shot that. Yes. You talk. It's you.
那我怎么在里面？哦，他们把我放到了屏幕上？迈克尔有一个电视屏幕。是的。然后你的角色说，是的，我说我去不了，但迈克尔派了一个摄像团队到我家。哦，所以我拍了那个。你拍了那个。是的。你说话。那是你。
You did it. I don't remember that. Oh shot that. Yes, you talk, it's you. You did it. I don't remember that. Oh, that's cool. Yeah. I do remember getting the Dundee though, and they sent it to my house. It was very, it was pretty great.
你做到了。我不记得了。哦，拍了那个。是的，你说话，那是你。你做到了。我不记得了。哦，那太酷了。是的。不过我确实记得拿到了邓迪奖，他们把它寄到我家了。这真的很棒。
Oh, that's cool. Yeah, I got the little trophy. Yeah. So do you still have it that says hottest in the office? I don't know. Oh, that would be great to have for your shelf. Yeah. Yes. I have two and this will go next to it greatest world's best podcast guest. Yay, our coffee mug. I have two
哦，那太酷了。是的，我得到了那个小奖杯。是的。那你还留着那个上面写着办公室最性感的奖杯吗？我不知道。哦，放在你的书架上一定很棒。是的。我有两个，这个将放在它旁边，世界上最棒的播客嘉宾。耶，我们的咖啡杯。我有两个
world's greatest dads. I've won it twice. Aw, that's so cute. Yeah. Now I've been a father for 25 years, but I've only got it twice. And you have three children. I have three children. Have only two awarded you this award. By the way, that's a good question. Or is it the same kid? I don't know.
世界上最棒的爸爸。我拿过两次。哦，这太可爱了。是的。现在我当爸爸已经 25 年了，但我只拿到过两次。而且你有三个孩子。我有三个孩子。只有两个孩子颁给你了这个奖。顺便说一句，这是个好问题。还是同一个孩子？我不知道。
I just like that for some reason I have two of them. Somewhere along the line, they either forgot they gave me one or they're like, let's get it to them again. Yeah, he really likes that. Let's give him another one. And I don't know if I am the world's greatest dad because I don't even remember who gave it to me or why or when I got it, I just know I have two. Well.
我只是觉得出于某种原因我有两个。在某个时候，他们要么忘了他们给过我一个，要么他们就在想，再给他一次吧。是的，他真的很喜欢那个。再给他一个。而且我不知道我是不是世界上最棒的爸爸，因为我甚至不记得是谁给我的，为什么给的，或者什么时候得到的，我只知道我有两个。好吧。
And I've always liked having the two side by side. And I think for a second, the Dundee might have been there. I'm a bit of a minimalist at the house, I don't tend to keep a lot of stuff. That's good. That's smart. Oh, very good. Yeah, yeah, I mean I-
而且我一直很喜欢把这两个并排摆放。我觉得有一秒钟，邓迪奖可能就在那儿。我在家里有点极简主义，我不太倾向于保留很多东西。那挺好的。那很聪明。哦，非常好。是的，是的，我的意思是——
Let me turn that frown around. So I don't remember the looking at the camera bits. Okay. But it sounds like a winner. You did it really well. That's great. Okay, cool. I don't remember anything being difficult about the show.
让我扭转那个愁容。所以我不记得看摄像机的那些片段了。好吧。但听起来是个赢家。你做得很好。那太好了，酷。我不记得节目有什么困难的地方。
I remember, other than, I do remember laughing. I'm sure I screwed up what would have been a really good scene, because with Correll, where I was, I just couldn't stop laughing, because it was so intense and funny and there's a little bit of disappointment still there that I could not keep a straight face. Is it when you're trying to leave the building? Yes.
我记得，除了，我确实记得笑场。我确信我搞砸了一个本来会非常精彩的场景，因为和卡瑞尔在一起时，我，我就是停不下来大笑，因为它太激烈太搞笑了，而且直到现在我还带着一丝失望，因为我没能保持住严肃的面部表情。是当你们试图离开大楼的时候吗？是的。
Yes, it's in the bloopers. Yeah, so at least it's got a life somewhere because he's incredible and he's fully committed and I'm quite certain, I haven't seen it in a long, you know, but that I'm the one busting up more than he is. I'm sure I'm busting up and then, and that's making him then laugh. But he was really impressive. Oh yeah, he doesn't break. He's like a statue. It's really hard to make him laugh.
是的，在NG花絮里。是的，所以至少它在某个地方留存下来了，因为他太不可思议了，而且他全身心投入，我相当确定，虽然我很久没看了，你知道的，但我才是那个笑得比他还厉害的人。我确信我笑场了，然后，这反过来又让他笑了。但他真的很让人印象深刻。哦，是的，他不会笑场。他就像一尊雕像。想让他笑真的很难。
Yeah, I know. He was very committed. I have fond memories of my experience, you know, just in general. I just remember enjoying the whole thing. And you guys were all wonderful pros, great vibe. You'd already been on the air for a while. Yeah, it was season seven, but it was always so fun when someone new came in because that new energy that it would bring to the set. And I loved it so much. I rewatched it. The
是的，我知道。他非常投入。我对我的经历有着美好的回忆，你知道的，总体而言。我只记得我很享受整个过程。而且你们都是出色的专业人士，氛围很好。你们当时已经播了一段时间了。是的，那是第七季，但每当有新人加入时总是那么有趣，因为那会给剧组带来新的活力。我太喜欢了。我重温了它。
fact that Danny Cordray thinks Pam is a dork. And that's why, do you remember our storyline? It's coming back to me now. Yeah, so we had gone on a couple of dates when Jim was away. Two dates. Two dates, and it was supposed to be a third, but then you didn't call me back. And, but you try to tell Jim that it was that I didn't call you back. And so I say, no, no, no.
事实上，丹尼·科德雷觉得帕姆是个书呆子。这就是为什么，你还记得我们的剧情吗？现在我想起来了。是的，所以在吉姆不在的时候我们约会过几次。两次。两次，本来应该有第三次的，但你后来没给我回电话。而且，你试图告诉吉姆说是我没给你回电话。所以我就说，不，不，不。
And then we will not leave you alone. We're like, he has this great scene where he's like, man, why didn't you call her back? And you're like, for real, you wanna know why I didn't call your wife back for a date like five years ago? And you eventually admit that it's because you thought I was a little dorky.
然后我们就一直缠着你。我们就像是，他有一个很棒的场景，他会说，老兄，你为什么不给她回电话？然后你就说，真的吗，你想知道我为什么在大概五年前不给你老婆回电话吗？你最终承认那是因为你觉得我有点书呆子气。
And it's so great and it was so fun. What's so cute too? That's so wonderful. It's such a great scene. And when you finally admit it that she's, that Pam's a little dorky, I watched it with my son who's 16 and he turned to me and he goes, this is so cringy. Well, I'm dressed as olive oil. I'm in a full Halloween costume.
这太棒了，而且太有趣了。还有什么很可爱？这太美妙了。这真是一个伟大的场景。当你在最后承认她，也就是帕姆有点书呆子气时，我和我 16 岁的儿子一起看了这一集，他转过身对我说，这太尴尬了。好吧，我打扮成橄榄油。我穿着一套万圣节服装。
And so I am being pretty dorky. And she goes, when you call her dorky, she goes, oh, OK. Blah, blah, excuse me. And it's so funny. Do you remember that too? Yeah. That's so fun. I love that storyline so much.
所以我表现得很像个呆子。然后她觉得，当你说她呆计时，她说，哦，好吧。胡说八道，打扰一下。这太搞笑了。你也记得那个吗？对。太好玩了。我太喜欢那个剧情线了。
I want to ask you about The Sting. That's the first. I love that storyline so much. I want to ask you about the sting. That's the first episode where you show up and you're this salesman and Michael's gonna try to figure out why are you so good? You're this rival salesperson. Yeah. And so they set up that fake office. Yeah.
我想问你关于《骗中骗》的事。那是第一部。我太喜欢那个剧情线了。我想问你关于《骗中骗》的事。那是第一集，你出场了，你演一个推销员，迈克尔想要弄清楚为什么你这么厉害？你是个竞争对手推销员。对。于是他们布置了那个假办公室。对。
And then Meredith is an Oscar come in. Meredith, wait, her name is something Van Helsing. What is it? Do you remember? Dwight Nutter. I mean, I do remember, I remember, now a lot of this is coming back to me now, but I do remember the sting.
然后梅雷迪思和奥斯卡进来了。梅雷迪思，等等，她名字叫范海辛什么的。叫什么来着？你记得吗？德怀特·纳特。我是说，我确实记得，我记得，现在很多记忆都回想起来了，但我确实记得《骗中骗》。
Remember that scene being in the office and her acting like she's super rich and in charge or something like that. Yes, yeah. And people are coming in and out. Yes, because she starts to really hit on you. And so they're like, ah, she's going to ruin it. Send in Oscar. And then Oscar comes in and she's literally like, he's here to clean. He speaks no English. And then they send in Ryan the temp. And she's like, that's Esteban. He does floors. Like,
记得那个在办公室的场景，她装得自己超级富有、很有权势之类的。是的，没错。然后人们进进出出。是的，因为她开始对你发起猛烈追求。于是他们就想，啊，她要搞砸了。派奥斯卡上。接着奥斯卡进去了，她居然说，他是来打扫卫生的。他一句英语都不会说。然后他们又派了临时工瑞安进去。她就说，那是埃斯特班。他负责铺地板。就像是，
so she keeps like thwarting their plans. Yes. It's really fun. It is a show. how long ago is that? It's a long time. It's been, my God, how long ago now? I mean, we probably shot that in 2010. Yeah. I mean, 15 years ago. Yeah.
所以她一直在破坏他们的计划。是的。真的很有趣。这是一部剧。那是多久以前的事了？那是很久以前了。天哪，现在过去多久了？我的意思是，我们大概是2010年拍的。对。我是说，15年前了。对。
Yeah. People still will be like, you know. Yeah, do you already guys for the recording? Yeah, I'll get the occasional like, you know. Yeah, do you recognize for the recording? Yeah, I'll get, you know, the occasional like, hey, were you in the office? Yeah. That happens. That happens.
对。人们还是会说，你知道的。对，你们录制准备好了吗？对，我偶尔会听到那种，你知道的。对，你们为录制准备好了吗？对，我偶尔会听到，你知道的，嘿，你是不是演过《办公室》？对。这确实会发生。这确实会发生。
I mean, that's so wild, because you have such amazing, huge, larger than life other characters. It's a huge, and also you get it from like teenagers and stuff. Yeah. It's amazing. Show that just keeps on giving. Yes. How cool to keeps on giving. Yes. How cool to be honest, you guys were
我的意思是，这太疯狂了，因为你们有那么多 amazing 的、巨大的、超越现实的其他角色。这是一个巨大的成就，而且你还能从青少年之类的群体那里感受到。太棒了。这部剧总是能给人带来惊喜。是的。说实话，你们能参与其中，
part of something that culturally relevant and huge. We had no idea at the time. Kind of amazing. Yeah. It was pretty wild. I mean, I don't have those kind of problems. You guys must get that craziness. People must go, hey, can you go to the airport?
成为如此具有文化相关性和轰动效应的作品的一部分，真的很酷。我们当时根本不知道。简直太神奇了。是的。这相当疯狂。我的意思是，我没有那种烦恼。你们一定经历过那种疯狂。人们肯定会跑过来，嘿，你能去机场吗？
What's it like when you go to the airport? It's nuts. I can go a lot of places. I really fly under the radar and I always have. I don't know if it's like some sort of like special gift or something. I don't know. But I, like I was once rear-ended by the paparazzi who were chasing Christina Ricci and I had to get out of my car and like exchange information with them, and they never took my photo. That's like how invisible I am to that world. Well, I would challenge you to fly Southwest to Austin and walk through that airport,
你去机场的时候是什么样子的？太疯狂了。我可以去很多地方。我真的非常低调，而且一直都是这样。我不知道这算不算是一种某种特殊的超能力什么的。我不知道。但是，有一次我被狗仔队追尾了，他们在追克里斯蒂娜·里奇，我不得不下车和他们交换保险信息，而他们居然连我的照片都没拍。这就是我对那个世界来说有多隐形。好吧，我敢打赌你坐西南航空去奥斯汀，穿过那个机场，
because you're gonna get recognized a lot. I think I can do it. I'll through that airport. Okay. Cause you're going to get recognized a lot. Okay. I do. I think I can do it. I get. I'll take that challenge. Let's go. We're taking the show Office Ladies on the Road.
因为你会被很多人认出来。我觉得我能做到。穿过那个机场。好吧。因为你会被认出来很多次。好吧。我觉得。我觉得我能做到。我会的。我接受这个挑战。我们走。我们将推出《办公室女士》公路版。
We're going to film one. I don't know. Guys, we're going to film one. I get recognized a ton at airports. Southwest terminal in Austin. It's a great town. You'll get recognized. I won't.
我们要去拍一集。我不知道。伙计们，我们要去拍一集。我在机场经常被认出来。奥斯汀的西南航空航站楼。那是个好地方。你会被人认出来的。我才不会。
It's in the budget. Let's go. It's in the budget. We could go talk to people about bread in Austin. I invited myself on the trip by the budget. Let's go. It's in the budget. We can go talk to people about bread and Austin. I invited myself on the trip by the way. You're on our spinoff show, Ops Ladies on the Road. Yeah, obviously it's on the road. Come on, that's a fun show.
这在预算之内。我们走。这在预算之内。我们可以去奥斯汀跟人们聊聊面包。顺便说一句，我自己主动加入这次旅行了。你在我们的衍生节目《办公室女士公路版》里。对，显然是在路上。拜访一下，那是个有趣的节目。
You're a man on the street. And then we have Bread of the Week. Bread of the Week, Southwest Austin. We're building a network show by show right now. I mean, you guys have a network. This is what you guys... Will you please be at our next think tank meeting? Because we have 44 episodes we have to film.
你是个街头采访员。然后我们还有周常面包。周常面包，西南航空奥斯汀站。我们现在一集一集地在打造一个网台节目。我是说，你们有一个网台。这就是你们……你们能参加我们的下一个智囊团会议吗？因为我们还有44集要拍。
I like that there have been already think tank meetings. Yes. Yes. Yeah. We've got one coming up in January. They don't come up often. Well, it's a holiday. So you're shutting it down.
我喜欢已经开过智囊团会议这件事。是的。是的。对。我们一月份有一个。它们不会经常开。好吧，这是个假期。所以你们要停工了。
We're taking some time. In January, you get to think tank. Yeah, we're going to think tank it. In January you get to think tank. Yeah, we're gonna think tank it. Okay. In the episode costume contest, Michael says you remind him of someone and Kelly says, is it Josh Duhamel? Fan question from Kiela V in Texas, do you often get confused for Josh Duhamel?
我们要休息一段时间。在一月份，你们可以开智囊团会议。对，我们要开智囊团会议。在一月份你们可以开智囊团会议。对，我们要开智囊团会议。好吧。在服装大赛那一集里，迈克尔说你让他想起某个人，凯利说，是乔什·杜哈明吗？德克萨斯州基拉·V的粉丝提问，你经常被人误认为是乔什·杜哈明吗？
Follow up, I heard he was on your Christmas card once. Yeah, so I've told this story before, so forgive me for it. So yes, obviously I do. But yeah, he was in my, he took a picture with, we were at an event together, we'd never met. But as soon as we saw each other, started laughing. And while we were talking, one of the Dodgers,
追问一下，我听说他曾经上过你的圣诞贺卡。是的，所以这个故事我以前讲过，请大家原谅我再讲一遍。所以是的，很显然我经常被认错。但是是的，他曾出现在我的，他和我拍过一张照片，我们以前从未见过面。但我们一看到对方，就开始大笑。当我们聊天的时候，其中一个道奇队的球员，
we were at a Dodgers event and one of the guys asked him if he was gonna be in any more Hitman movies, which is a movie I did, and he asked Josh in front of me. And it was really great. I watched him get mistaken for me in front of me. It was just wonderful. And then it occurred to me, I said, you know what?
我们在一个道奇队的活动上，其中一个人问他是否会参演更多的《杀手47》电影，那是我拍过的一部电影，他当着我的面问了乔什。这真的很棒。我看着他当着我的面被误认成了我。这简直太美妙了。然后我突然想到，我说，你知道吗？
I got my whole family here. Would you? And he knew right away, he's like, I'm in, you got it. So great. So he took a picture with my wife and three kids and we sent it as the holiday Christmas card. That's so awesome. My mom had it on the fridge and had noticed it.
我全家人都在这儿。你愿意……他马上就明白了，他说，我加入，没问题。太棒了。于是他和我妻子以及三个孩子拍了这张照片，我们把它当作了节日圣诞贺卡寄出去。太棒了。我妈妈把它贴在冰箱上，而且注意到了。
Didn't clock it. My brother called me, said, dude, mom had it on the fridge and had noticed it. Didn't clock it. My brother called me. He said, dude, mom had no idea. That's so great. I had to point it out to her and she said, I thought he looked taller. It's such a good story. It's a great story. So yeah, me and Josh, forever linked, lovely guy. He's a great sport about it.
根本没认出来。我哥哥打电话给我，说，老兄，妈妈把它贴在冰箱上，而且注意到了。根本没认出来。我哥哥打电话给我。他说，老兄，妈妈完全不知道。太棒了。我不得不指给她看，然后她说，我当时就觉得他个子更高一点。这故事真好。是个好故事。所以，对，我和乔什，永远联系在一起，非常可爱的一个人。他对此心态超级好。
Kind of funny. It's funny. Do you guys have one of those? Yeah. I've got a couple. Yeah? Yeah. I would get Amy Adams and Isla Fisher. Okay. And have you spoken to them about it? Yeah. Because you assume they also... Yes.
有点搞笑。这很有趣。你们有这种经历吗？有。我有几个。有吗？有。我会遇到艾米·亚当斯和艾拉·菲舍尔。好吧。你跟他们谈过这事吗？对。因为你觉得他们也……是的。
Or maybe she says, sometimes the paparazzis don't pay attention to me because they think I'm you. Yeah. She's like, they're like, go ahead, Jenna. Sometimes when I'm being ignored, I realize, oh, you guys think I'm Jenna. Yeah, exactly. No, one time at a party, Amy and I were both at the party. And the guy I was with at the time, he came up to me, and he's like, oh my god, I'm so embarrassed. I just went up and I put my arm around Amy Adams.
或者有时候她说，有时狗仔队不关注我，因为他们以为我是你。对。她会说，他们会说，走吧，詹娜。有时候当我被无视时，我意识到，哦，你们以为我是詹娜。对，没错。不，有一次在一个派对上，我和艾米都在派对上。当时和我在一起的那个人，他走过来对我说，哦天哪，我太尴尬了。我刚刚走过去，把胳膊搭在了艾米·亚当斯身上。
I thought it was you. I thought it was you. And I was like, nope, I'm over here. And then she came up and she was like, I met your date. It was so great to meet him. So yeah, so we've talked about it a little bit, but I don't, it's, I kind of see it. Did you also say NPS, don't put your arm around me in public.
我还以为是你。我还以为是你。然后我说，不，我在这儿呢。然后她走过来对我说，我刚见了你的女伴。见到他太棒了。所以，是的，我们稍微聊过这个，但我不会，我觉得，我多少能理解。你是不是还说过，附言：别在公众场合把胳膊搭在我身上？
I was like, I mean, we're not together anymore. See? I don't know. Yeah, yeah. Cause you overstepped with somebody else. Do you get one? I've gotten before a shorter version of Laura Dern, but like the short version. She's really tall.
我当时就想，我的意思是，我们已经不是那种关系了。你看？我不知道。对，对。因为你对别人越界了。你遇到过吗？我以前被认成是矮个版的劳拉·邓恩，就像短小版的她。她真的很高。
So I don't know. That's, I don't know. I don't know. What do you, that's all I got. But you don't have the doppelganger, showbiz doppelganger out there that you know you're being mistaken for because that's what we have. We have the, yeah, you know, I'll get giggles
所以我不知道。那是，我不知道。我不知道。你有什么，这就是我所有的经历了。但你没有那种替身，演艺圈的替身，你知道自己被误认成他，因为这就是我们遇到的情况。我们有，是的，你知道的，我会在柜台后面听到窃笑，
behind a counter and then I realize they don't know who I am. Yeah, right. They think I'm him. Yes. No, no. Although I really want to tell Laura Dern that someday, that like, hey, I'm your short version. Yeah, yeah. You should play her short sister in something.
然后我意识到他们不知道我是谁。是的，没错。他们以为我是他。是的，没有，没有。虽然我真的很想有一天告诉劳拉·邓恩，嘿，我是你的矮个版。对，对。你应该在什么作品里演她的矮个姐姐。
Yeah. I wanna ask you a little bit about Justified. Yes. I have only just started watching the series, but I am loving it. Thank you, it's a nice thing to say. Me too, my husband loved it. And then he had me start watching it, I love it.
对。我想问你一点关于《火线警探》的事。是的。我才刚刚开始看这部剧，但我非常喜欢它。谢谢，听到这话真高兴。我也是，我丈夫很喜欢。然后他让我开始看，我也很喜欢。
Oh, thank you. Do you still have the hat? Never kept it. What? You didn't keep your hat, you didn't keep your dundee? So, keep that in mind with the dundee, right, I didn't keep the hat, yeah. That is shocking to me.
哦，谢谢。你还留着那顶帽子吗？从来没留过。什么？你没留着你的帽子，也没留着邓迪奖？所以，记着邓迪奖的事，对吧，我没留那顶帽子，对。这让我很震惊。
What about from Deadwood, do you have your star? No, I didn't keep any. Do you take anything from sets? So yes, in that, like a pair of jeans or anything that's practical. So you're like, ooh, I like the fit of these, I'm gonna wear these. Oh, these are nothing sentimental. No, I never take anything sentimental. I take things that I'm like, oh, I like the fit of these. I'm gonna wear these. Oh, these are nothing sentimental.
《朽木》的那把星星徽章呢？没有，我什么都没留。你会从片场拿东西吗？所以是的，比如一条牛仔裤或者任何实用性的东西。所以你会想，哦，我喜欢这条裤子的版型，我要穿这个。哦，这些都不是什么有纪念意义的东西。不，我从不拿任何有纪念意义的东西。我拿的东西都是我想，哦，我喜欢这个版型。我要穿这个。哦，这些都不是什么有纪念意义的东西。
No, I never take anything sentimental. I take things that are like, oh, I could use some socks. Right. Yeah. No, like my kids will make fun of me. Like if I buy something, they'll be like, oh, dad bought a shirt. Because a lot of times I will just be wearing things
不，我从不拿有纪念意义的东西。我拿的都是那种，哦，我可能需要几双袜子。对。对。不，就像我的孩子们会拿我开玩笑。比如我买什么东西，他们就会说，哦，爸爸买了一件衬衫。因为很多时候我穿的衣服
that have like my character name or it either says like, you know, when they put inside, it either says hero or it says like, you know, Raelyn. Yeah, I'll have like a pair of jeans and inside it just says Raelyn or hero. Yeah, I'll have that. You know what- T-shirts, anything that's, those I'm take all,
上面写着我的角色名字，要么就是写着，你知道的，当他们缝在里面时，要么写着英雄，要么写着，你知道的，雷兰。对，我有一条牛仔裤，里面直接写着雷兰或英雄。对，我会留着这个。你知道——T恤，任何东西，那些我都拿，
I always tell the cost, you know, the customer, I would say, look, there's gonna be some things missing at the, so I just, I hope it's in the budget. It's just my clothes, my whatever. But I don't, I've never taken. That's how you shop. Yeah. And I will say, cause I always think to myself, what am I going to do with the hat? I mean, it's just going to sit there somewhere and take up space and I, I don't like having
我总是跟服装，你知道的，服装师说，我会说，听着，这儿会少一些东西，所以我只是，我希望这在预算之内。只是我的衣服，我的别的什么。但我没有，我从来没拿过。这就是你购物的方式。对。而且我会说，因为我总是在想，我拿这帽子能干嘛呢？我的意思是，它就只能搁在哪儿占地方，而且我讨厌
a, but. You don't, you're minimal at home. We've learned this. I'm a bit of a minimalist. I'm a bit of the, when I first heard about that Maria Kondo. Oh, right. I was like, oh, yeah, I got it. You're like, I do it already.
一个，但是。你不会，你在家里是个极简主义者。我们了解到了这一点。我算是个极简主义者。我有点像，当我第一次听说那个近藤麻理惠时。哦，对。我就想，哦，对，我懂。你就像是，我已经这么做了。
I'm there, but she added the little thank you for your service. You ever hear that little quote that she does? As you throw it away. As you throw it away? Or as you gift it. Yeah, yeah, I love that. I've added that.
我早就达到了，但她加了一句“感谢你的服务”。你听过她说的那个小名言吗？当你把它扔掉的时候。当你把它扔掉的时候？或者当你把它送人的时候。对，对，我喜欢那个。我也加上了这一句。
You pass it on. I've added that. Thank you for your service. Big fan. Thank you for your time here. Big fan of that. But I did keep a hat from the show. We did a thing, it's a spoiler, but we did a thing where there was a guy,
你把它传下去。我加上了这句。感谢你的服务。超级粉丝。感谢你在这里的时光。超级粉丝。但我确实从剧里留了一顶帽子。我们拍了一场戏，这是剧透，但我们拍了一场戏，有个家伙，
a villain with a hat towards the very end of this, the original show's ending. And I wore this hat, I took the dead guy's hat because he shot my hat. I had a whole, we had a whole story. Anyway, I took that hat and then had it refitted so that I could just wear like a free hat. Yeah. It was a little bit along that practical thing. I was like, I'd love to get a free hat out of this. Right.
一个戴帽子的反派，在原剧结局的尾声。我戴了这顶帽子，我拿了那个死掉的家伙的帽子，因为他打中了我的帽子。我有一整套，我们有一整套故事。不管怎样，我拿了那顶帽子，然后重新调整了尺寸，这样我就可以当作一顶免费的帽子来戴了。对。这有点符合实用主义。我当时就想，我很乐意从这弄到一顶免费的帽子。对。
But I don't want to want that hat, the D hat. So I got another hat. You wouldn't recognize it as the hat from the show, because you just have it re-blocked. I kind of wish I did that with the Raylan hat. Yeah. Just took it and then just had it. I forget you can just have a hat re-blocked and just make it into, it's not even recognizable. It'd be a fun fact to say, yeah, this is a Raylan hat. Yeah. There it is. Yeah.
但我不想想要那顶帽子，那顶D帽。所以我拿了另一顶帽子。你不会认出那是剧里的帽子，因为你只是把它重新定型了。我有点希望我对雷兰的帽子也这么做了。对。直接拿走然后把它。我忘了你完全可以把一顶帽子重新定型，把它变成，甚至都认不出来了。这会是个有趣的事实，可以跟人说，对，这是雷兰的帽子。对。就是这样。对。
It just re- But I just like how it looks. Yeah, just change it around. I have a little story for us. Well, two things. One, I have a question from Julio in Clinton, New Jersey. Julio says, which office character would best survive the justified universe? I'm going with Creed.
它只是重——但我就是喜欢它的样子。对，就是改一下。我有个小故事要讲。好吧，两件事。第一，我有来自新泽西州克林顿的胡里奥的一个问题。胡里奥问，《办公室》里的哪个角色最能在《火线警探》的宇宙中生存下来？我选克里德。
Okay. I think he is in that world. He's sort of a criminal, but also sort of not. He's questionable. I feel like a marshal would be needed to track him in some way. To wrangle him. Yep. They all would have been great. Because everyone on your show is so good at comedy,
好吧。我觉得他就是属于那个世界的人。他有点像个罪犯，但又有点不像。他很可疑。我觉得需要一个法警以某种方式追踪他。去管束他。对。他们所有人都会很棒。因为你们剧组的每个人都很擅长喜剧，
but not acknowledging the comedy without pointing it out, which is kind of what we were doing a little bit. Very much. Nothing more fun than taking someone who's like known for sitcom and putting them in like a cool gritty like comedic performance on our show. That was always my favorite thing. I always love that when I watch a show to see someone from a world that's like totally different.
却又不露声色地表现出喜剧效果，而不去刻意指出它，这正是我们当时在做的事情。非常如此。没有什么比把一个以情景喜剧闻名的人拉进来，让他们在我们的剧里进行那种酷炫、 gritty（硬核/粗粝）的喜剧表演更有趣了。那一直是我的最爱。当我看到一部完全不同世界的演员时，我总是非常喜欢。
I think your character was that on The Office too for a lot of people. That was really cool. Yeah, because your time on The Office was after Deadwood but before Justified. Okay, I'll take your word for it. It was. So if you had watched Deadwood.
我觉得你的角色在《办公室》里对很多人来说也是这样的存在。那真的很酷。对，因为你在《办公室》的时间在《朽木》之后，但在《火线警探》之前。好吧，我就信你的话了。确实是。所以如果你看过《朽木》。
It's all a bit of a blur. Yeah, as a Deadwood fan, which I was, you know, we had, that was a thing that we did on the show a lot. Like we had a lot of folks who had been on The Sting. Wait, is that the name of the show? No, The Wire. I was gonna say them.
这一切都有点记不清了。对，作为《朽木》的粉丝，我确实是，你知道的，我们剧里经常这么做。比如我们有很多演员都演过《骗中骗》。等等，那是节目的名字吗？不，《火线监听》（The Wire）。我本想说那个。
It's like, wow. We're professionals. Oh, hold on. Timothy. Can I just tell you, this is our last show of 2024. You had, you had. Can you feel it? You had Redford, Newman, who else did you have from The Sting?
就像，哇。我们是专业人士。哦，等等。蒂莫西。我能跟你说吗？这是我们2024年的最后一期节目。你有，你有。你能感受到吗？你有罗伯特·雷德福，保罗·纽曼，你们《骗中骗》里还有谁？
They were all in... Jacky Gleason. Gleason. He was in it? Amazing. They were great on the show. I forgot Jacky Gleason was in The Sting. Have you watched The Sting in a while?
他们都在……杰基·格里森。格里森。他也在里面？太惊人了。他们在剧里表现得很棒。我忘了杰基·格里森演过《骗中骗》。你最近看过《骗中骗》吗？
I have. Because it holds up and it's fantastic. I have. It's one of my favorite movies. I would look, you know, I keep a list of things and I want to say I watched it like a year or two ago. Same. I haven't seen it in a while. Really solid. All right. So good. Just wonderful performances.
我看过。因为这部电影经久不衰，而且棒极了。我看过。这是我最喜欢的电影之一。我会看，你知道的，我列了个清单，我想说我大概一两年 以前看过。我也是。我好久没看过这部电影了。非常扎实。没错。太棒了。表演简直太精彩了。
I mean just, wow. It's that ending. It's just like you love everybody, right? Yeah. When they're all closing up shop, giving them a little... On the nose. Now I need to rewatch it. It's so wonderful. flavors of pistachio or shake up your mood with an iced brown sugar oat shaken espresso. Whatever you choose, your espresso will be handcrafted with care at Starbucks. I found a little something on YouTube that I want to talk to you about. Okay. Well. I'm leaning in. So everybody's leaning in. You should have teased that.
我的意思是，哇。那个结局。就好像你爱所有人，对吧？对。当他们收摊的时候，给他们一个微小的……太直白了。现在我得重新看一遍了。太美妙了。开心果风味，或者用一杯冰红糖燕麦摇摇意式浓缩来改变你的心情。无论你选择什么，你的意式浓缩都将在星巴克用心手工制作。我在YouTube上发现了一些小东西，我想跟你聊聊。好吧。好吧。我正探过身子听呢。所以大家都探过身子听。你刚才应该先卖个关子的。
By the way, put that in the front of the show. I found a little thing on YouTube I want to ask you about. But we'll get that in a little bit. We'll get to that later. And then people will really stick around. Stay tuned. Why do you think we've lost them? What are you saying?
顺便说一句，把这个放在节目开头。我在YouTube上发现了一个小东西，我想问你关于它的事。但我们待会儿再聊那个。我们晚点再聊这个。然后人们就会真的留下来。敬请期待。你觉得我们为什么会失去他们？你在说什么？
All right. What do you got on you? By the way, let's circle back to that thing you were saying on YouTube. Yes. See what I did there? Thank you. Thank you.
好吧。你有什么料？顺便说一句，我们绕回来谈谈你在YouTube上说的那个东西。吧。看我刚才那招怎么样？谢谢。谢谢。
If you just do this for us, we have some ads for you later, too. Oh, I'd love to sit in on the ads. Oh, you're so funny when you read ads on Conan. I love it. Oh, thank you. That made me laugh so hard. Yeah, I read ads on Conan. I love it. Oh, thank you. That made me laugh so hard. Yeah, I read ads on Conan. It's really funny. Okay, YouTube. Here we go. Okay. It was April 2015. Okay. You were a guest. I'm right there. You were a guest on Conan O'Brien. Uh huh. Justified last episode was that night. There was going to be a party.
如果你能为我们做这个，我们待会儿还有一些广告要播。哦，我很乐意坐下来听你们播广告。哦，你在柯南的节目里读广告时太搞笑了。我太喜欢了。哦，谢谢。那把我逗得太厉害了。对，我在柯南节目里读广告。我太喜欢了。哦，谢谢。那把我逗得太厉害了。对，我在柯南节目里读广告。真的很好笑。好吧，YouTube。我们开始吧。好吧。那是2015年4月。好吧。你当时是嘉宾。我就坐在那儿。你是柯南·奥布莱恩的嘉宾。嗯哼。那天晚上是《火线警探》的最后一集。将会有一场派对。
You bring onto Conan a mason jar of whiskey from Kentucky. And you and Conan and Andy all drank whiskey during the interview. Yeah. I was the second guest that night. And I came out and you poured me a whiskey. You didn't realize it was real whiskey. I was like, surely this isn't real whiskey.
你带了一罐来自肯塔基州的威士忌Mason jar到柯南的节目上。然后你、柯南和安迪在采访期间都喝了威士忌。对。我那天晚上是第二个嘉宾。我走出来，你给我倒了一杯威士忌。你没意识到那是真威士忌。我当时想，这绝对不可能是真威士忌。
And I took a big slug of it. Yeah, I remember. And I was like, oh wow, that's real whiskey. So that is the first time I've ever drank on television. And I rewatched the interview. You totally are great. First of all, that you guys were sipping. And then I come out, I take my slug of whiskey, and I am so like wackadoodle in the interview. I don't know. No, you're being tough on yourself. No, no, no. It was really good whiskey. And I totally thought it was a bit. And I didn't know. No, you're being tough on yourself. No, no, no.
然后我大大地喝了一大口。对，我记得。我就想，哦哇，那是真威士忌。所以那是我有生以来第一次在电视上喝酒。然后我重看了那段采访。你表现得完全太棒了。首先，你们当时在小口啜饮。然后我走出来，喝了一大口威士忌，我在采访里简直就像个怪咖。我不知道。不，你对自己太苛刻了。不，不，不。那是很好的威士忌。我完全以为这只是个段子，我不知道。不，你对自己太苛刻了。不，不，不。
It was really good whiskey and I totally thought it was a bit and I didn't think it was actual whiskey. Yeah, we committed. We committed. You guys are very committed. Timothy, we shared with our listeners that you and I recently connected at our mutual friend's birthday party. And I got to meet your wife of 30 years. Yep. Don't mess me up. 30 something, I think. Go ahead. She is amazing. Thank you. I'm a wife. Thank you. But that's nice of you to say.
那是很好的威士忌，我完全以为这只是个段子，根本没想到那是真威士忌。对，我们豁出去了。我们豁出去了。你们真的很投入。蒂莫西，我们跟听众分享过，你和我在我们共同朋友的生日派对上最近联系上了。我还见到了你结婚30年的妻子。对。别把我弄砸了。30多年吧，我想。你接着说。她太棒了。谢谢。我是个好丈夫。谢谢。不过你这么说真好。
Okay. I agree. We got a fan question from Kim P in Chicago who said, the sexiest thing about you is your long relationship with your wife. Would you be willing to tell us your meat cute? Oh, we're separating. You are not, you are not. I have to assume that when you met her, you knew immediately that you needed to marry this person. She is one of the most phenomenal human beings I have ever met.
好吧。我同意。我们收到了来自芝加哥的吉姆·P的一个粉丝提问，他说，关于你最性感的一点是你和妻子长久的婚姻关系。你愿意跟我们讲讲你们的浪漫初遇吗？哦，我们要分居了。你才没有，你才没有。我必须假设，当你遇见她时，你立刻就知道你需要娶这个人。她是我见过的最了不起的人类之一。
One of the strongest, best first impressions a human has ever made on me. Your wife is like, she is, Alexis is like a gem of a human being. Oh, that's lovely to hear. I will pass that on to her. I mean, how did you do it? Because she's never seen anything I've ever been in.
这是我所见过的人类留下的最深刻、最好的第一印象之一。你的妻子就像是，她是，亚历克西斯就像人类中的一颗明珠。哦，听到这话真高兴。我会把这话转达给她的。我是说，你是怎么做到的？因为她从来没看过我演的任何东西。
And so. But that's kind of true, isn't it? What part? That she doesn't like really engage in the whole like Hollywood thing. No, no. We met in college and- Where'd you go to college? We went to USC. Yeah. We met in college. And where did you go to college?
所以。但这也算有点真实，不是吗？哪部分？就是她不太参与好莱坞的那种圈子。不，不。我们在大学认识的，而且——你在哪儿上的大学？我们去的是南加州大学（USC）。对。我们在大学认识的。你在哪儿上的大学？
We went to USC. OK. Junior year of college. Yeah, we were 20. And we were in a class, oceanography. That's a cool class. It was like a science requirement. And I was swimming at SC.
我们去的是南加州大学。好吧。大三的时候。对，我们20岁。我们在上一个海洋学班。那是个很酷的课。那是一个科学必修课。我当时在南加州大学游泳。
All the athletes, basically, we had the, you know, the athletes got the counselor. They all said you're taking oceanography, like that's your science and it's super fun class and it's really popular. There's this guy, Pipkin, professor there. It was a fun class. Anyway. Is it like the easy science class? I think that was the idea. Like all the athletes were like, you should take oceanography because that'll satisfy your science and it's kind of a big easy class and it's popular. They probably also just liked all the athletes taking the one class. The same. Because we're all getting the same tutor. We're all being tutored to get through it.
基本上所有的运动员，我们都有，你知道的，运动员都有辅导员。他们都说你们得去上海洋学，那是你们的科学课，而且这是一门超级好玩又非常受欢迎的课。那里有个叫皮普金的教授。那是一门有趣的课。不管怎样。是不是那种很轻松的科学课？我想这就是初衷。就像所有的运动员都说，你应该去上海洋学，因为那可以满足你的科学学分，而且这是一门比较轻松的大课，很受欢迎。他们可能也只是喜欢所有的运动员都去上同一门课。没错。因为我们都在接受同一个辅导员辅导。我们都在接受辅导以通过考试。
We had a class like that they called Shake and Bake because it was earthquakes and natural disasters. And all the athletes were in it. There you go. So that's your Shake and Bake. Yeah. Ocean Island. And you got a field trip to... Catalina Island. were in it. There you go. So that's your shake and bake. Yeah, oceanography and you got a field trip to Catalina Island. To Catalina. So you'd go out on the boat and go out there and go swimming, snorkeling Catalina because Essie's got like a oceanography institute out there. Oh that's cool. Yeah. So she was in the class? She was in the class. She used to come in late. One of the last people to come in, so I'd always see her coming in. And to
我们当时也有一门那样的课，叫“摇滚与烘焙”（Shake and Bake），因为那是关于地震和自然灾害的。所有的运动员都在里面。你看。所以这就是你们的“摇滚与烘焙”。对。海洋学，你们还能去进行一次实地考察……卡特琳娜岛。都在里面。你看。所以这就是你们的“摇滚与烘焙”。对，海洋学，你们还有去卡特琳娜岛的实地考察。去卡特琳娜。所以你们会坐船出去，去那里游泳、浮潜，因为南加州大学在那儿有一个海洋学研究所。哦，那太酷了。对。所以她也在这门课上？她在这门课上。她总是迟到。是最后几个进教室的人之一，所以我总是看到她走进来。而且为了
your point, I began referring to her as my girlfriend. We'd never met, but I was like, that's my girlfriend. I need to save her a spot because she comes in late and she'll have to come up and sit next to me. So, yeah, that's we had met taking oceanography class. We had friends in common. Yeah, we first met. I introduced myself to her after class. That's so cute. And the rest is history.
回应你刚才的话，我开始称她为我的女朋友。我们当时还不认识，但我心里想，那就是我的女朋友。我得帮她占个位子，因为她总是迟到，而且她得走过来坐在我旁边。所以，对，我们在海洋学课上认识的。我们有共同的朋友。对，我们第一次见面。下课后我自我介绍了。太可爱了。然后剩下的就是历史了。
Yep. All right. You've been so generous with your time. Well, it's kind of you. The last thing that we have. It's been a pleasure. I appreciate the invitation. Oh, thank you. have. The last thing that we have. It's been a pleasure. I appreciate the invitation. Oh, thank you.
对。好了。你对我们的时间太慷慨了。好吧，你太客气了。我们最后要。这真是个荣幸。我很感激能受到邀请。哦，谢谢。要。我们最后要。这真是个荣幸。我很感激能受到邀请。哦，谢谢。
Yeah. The last thing we do on the show is season five of Office Ladies. The last thing we do on the show are our call sheet questions. These are questions that we would ask members of our cast and crew, and then we would put their little answers on. The back of the call sheet.
对。我们在节目中做的最后一件事是《办公室女士》第五季。我们在节目中做的最后的事情是我们的点名单（Call Sheet）问题。这些问题是我们会问演员和剧组人员的问题，然后把他们的小答案写在。点名单的背面。
Yeah, we'd put their answers on the back of our call sheets. We didn't do this. Like, the production office did it. But it was such a fun thing on the set of the call sheet. Yeah, we'd put their answers on the back of our call sheets. We didn't do this like the production office did it, but it was such a fun thing on the set of the office. And it's how people like you learned a little bit about the cast or crew. It's a lovely show. I know it's not wonderful. Yeah. So you guys are dominating the world with your show and just and just making all this and also with the lovely kind of wonderful atmosphere and feel good. The camaraderie, yeah. The camaraderie. It was like a family, really.
对，我们会把他们的答案写在点名单背面。我们可没干这事。这其实是制作办公室干的。但这确实是点名单片场的一件趣事。对，我们会把他们的答案写在点名单背面。我们没干这事，是制作办公室干的，但这确实是办公室片场的一件趣事。这也是像你这样的人了解演员或剧组一点信息的方式。这节目真不错。我知道，不是很棒吗？对。所以你们用你们的节目统治了世界，而且还创造了所有这些，同时还营造了这种可爱、友善、美妙的氛围和治愈感。情谊，对。这份情谊。真的就像一个家庭一样。
Yeah. Yeah. So you want to kick it off, lady? Sure. Okay. First question is, what was your first job? It could be your first paid acting job or maybe your first job in general? As far as I can remember, I think we would be accepting two answers, either lifeguarding
对。对。女士，你想开个头吗？当然。好的。第一个问题是，你的第一份工作是什么？可以是你的第一份带薪表演工作，或者也许就是你的总的来说的第一份工作？据我所能记起来的，我觉得我们可以接受两个答案，要么是救生员，
or swim coaching. I think I coached. Yeah, those are probably the two jobs I kind of did when I was growing up. Used to give swim lessons. Yeah. Because I was a swimmer. All right, so we're going gonna go with lifeguarding.
要么是游泳教练。我觉得我当过教练。对，那可能是我成长过程中做过的两份工作。以前教过游泳。对，因为我以前是个游泳运动员。好吧，那我们就选救生员吧。
Lifeguarding. Lifeguarding. Yeah. All right, do you play a musical instrument? I play guitar, not well, but I play it. I played it a couple of times for a movie, and never got into it for a couple of different jobs, but learned it well enough for the job.
救生员。救生员。对。好吧，你会演奏什么乐器吗？我会弹吉他，虽然弹得不好，但我会弹。我为了拍电影弹过几次，从来没有为了某些具体的工作深入去学，不过为了工作学得足够应付就行了。
And then just a few years ago, either pandemic or strike, I mean, just not long ago, my daughter who's a very good singer-songwriter, she was like, dad, you should play guitar with me. So I started playing guitar with her and that got me into it. That is so sweet.
然后就在几年前，不管是疫情还是罢工期间，我的意思是，就在不久前，我的女儿，她是一个非常优秀的创作歌手，她对我说，爸爸，你应该跟我一起弹吉他。于是我开始和她一起弹吉他，这让我真正迷上了它。这太甜蜜了。
So I owe her some thanks. Next question, what's a place that you've been to that you absolutely loved? Oh well I love the Carmel, the sort of northern California. Carmel has always been a very, they can put as many bad art galleries and cuties, but, I still, I love it. I don't care how many they, that's how great that place is. They can shove, they've shoved so much bad art in that little community and I'm still like, yeah, it's great. I love it. Can't ruin it. I just love that coast and that is always, I've always had a soft spot for it. And we used to go there as kids, not so, not far from Modesto. And my wife and I always go, we honeymoon there.
所以我得感谢她。下一个问题，你去过哪个地方是你绝对热爱的？哦，好吧，我很喜欢卡梅尔，北加州的那种地方。卡梅尔一直是一个非常，他们可以塞进去那么多糟糕的艺术画廊和可爱的小玩意，但是，我依然，我很喜欢它。我才不管他们塞了多少，这就是那个地方的伟大之处。他们塞了那么多糟糕的艺术在这个小社区里，而我依然觉得，是的，太棒了。我太喜欢了。毁不掉的。我就是喜欢那片海岸，而且那一直是，我一直对它情有独钟。我们小时候经常去那儿，离莫德斯托不远。我和我妻子总是去，我们在那度过蜜月。
I love that area. All right. I've got the next one. What do you like to do on the weekends? These days? Sure. Yeah. So we, I swim early Saturday morning. This is like the routine. I swim early Saturday morning,
我很喜欢那个区域。好的。轮到我了。你周末喜欢做什么？这几天？当然。对。所以我们，我周六一大早去游泳。这就像是例行公事。我周六一大早游泳，
this is like the routine, I swim early Saturdays. You still swim? Still swim. Okay. I've gotten way back into, I don't know why, it's like a thing. My wife dragged me, I've always swam, but a few years ago I was working in Tribeca
这就像是例行公事，我周六游泳。你还在游泳？还在游泳。好吧。我重新开始游了，我不知道为什么，这就像是个习惯。我妻子把我拉进去的，我一直都在游泳，但几年前我在纽约和亚历克斯·温特一起在翠贝卡拍戏，
with Alex Winter in New York, and my wife is like, oh, we found a pool, we usually do. And then there was a master's program there. And she's like, let's do masters, you know, where you kind of like are with a group and there's a coach. And I was like, I don't want to do that. Come on. And then I did it. And I love it. I'm like, yeah. So now, yeah, swim over it. So I swim usually Saturday mornings. Lately, we have a, my wife and I share an art studio with our son. If we're really a mellow weekend, we'll go to, we like a Saturday in the art studio. It's kind of great. I mean, if we're just hanging in town, dog walks, our kids are wearing empty nesters, so it's just chill time. We do whatever. We're done with the
我妻子就说，哦，我们找到了一个游泳池，我们经常这么做。然后那里有一个“大师班”游泳项目。她就说，我们去上大师班吧，你知道的，就是跟一群人一起并且有教练的那种。当时我是拒绝的。拜托。然后我参加了。我太喜欢了。我就想，耶。所以现在，对，基本上是游完。所以我通常周六早上游泳。最近，我们有一个，我和妻子跟我们的儿子共用一个艺术工作室。如果我们周末真的很休闲，我们会去，我们很享受在艺术工作室度过的周六。感觉挺棒的。我的意思是，如果我们只是待在城里，遛狗，我们的孩子都长大了，我们是空巢老人，所以这就是轻松的时光。我们随心所欲。我们已经结束了
like, taking kids to a tennis tournament or whatever. Yeah. Which is kind of nice. That sounds really chill. May play tennis over the weekend. I play with my kid. I play with my brother. Yes, weekends, weekends are pretty chill. Sunday more like just Sunday tend to be stick around the house. Yeah. Like chore day kind of chores. Like, do you have a Sunday chore? Angela, I'm in show business. I grew up doing so many chores. Did you guys have chores?
那种带孩子去网球锦标赛之类的生活。对。这其实挺不错的。听起来真的很轻松。周末可能会打网球。我和我的孩子一起打。我和我兄弟一起打。是的，周末，周末通常挺休闲的。周日更像是就在家里待着。对。就像做家务的日子那种家务。比如，你周日有什么家务吗？安吉拉，我在演艺圈工作。我从小到大做过太多家务了。你们小时候有做过家务吗？
I was a chore. You were a chore person growing up. You had chores. We had major chores. Major chores. My buddies were like, dude, I was like, I just got to do my chores and then I'm free. And they were like, oh, yeah.
我就是个家务。你从小就是个爱干家务的人。你得做家务。我们有重大家务。重大家务。我的死党们会说，老兄，我当时就想，我得把家务做完然后我就自由了。他们就会说，哦，真的吗？
And now my kids, I don't think they know, they'd be like, chore, what is that? Look it up in the dictionary. I know. I know. That's a chore. We decided to have chore day and we told our kids they have to load the dishwasher. What? That's a ****? Yes. Oh my God. You know what my chores were growing up? Load the dishwasher. Well, listen, I'm in Los Angeles. That's a routine. That's not a chore. Yes, thank you. That's a-
现在我的孩子们，我觉得他们根本不知道，他们会觉得，家务，那是什么？去字典里查查吧。我知道。我知道。那是家务。我们决定设立家务日，我们告诉孩子们他们必须装洗碗机。什么？那也算家务？是的。哦天哪。你知道我小时候的家务是什么吗？装洗碗机。好吧，听着，我在洛杉矶。那是日常常规。那不叫家务。是的，谢谢。那是一个——
But they're 14. But let me tell you, you have a- Wait, that's still. What, what are you- How do you mean that? But they're 14. But like, why, like we're in Los Angeles, it's not like, listen, in Archer City, Texas,
但他们才14岁。但让我告诉你，你有一个——等等，那依然是。什么，你在——你这话什么意思？但他们才14岁。但为什么，就像我们在洛杉矶，又不是说，听着，在德克萨斯州阿彻城，
chores were like, go, you, I had friends that had to milk the cows. Yeah. We had to go collect eggs, we had to clean out ponds, we had to like mow lawns, and we had to like prune and weed and like, we had like chores.
家务是那种，去，你，我有朋友得去挤牛奶。对。我们得去捡鸡蛋，我们得清理池塘，我们得割草，我们还得修剪、除草，我们得干那种家务。
It was like, there was a wheelbarrow involved. Anyway. We had a wheelbarrow involved, there was something that took gasoline. Yes. That was a chore. I rode with my dad where he bailed hay. It was like chopping, we had like, you know,
就像，那是有独轮车参与的。不管怎样。有独轮车参与，还有需要用到汽油的设备。对。那才叫家务。我和我爸爸一起去打草捆。就像砍柴，我们有，你知道的，
there was something involved that you might get, like there might be blisters. No, I'm not saying. There was a shed, we had to go out to the shed. Okay, fine. Keeping them grounded. Well, anyway. Let's hear it. I want you to know.
会有那种你可能会受伤、可能会起水泡的活儿。不，我不是说。那里有个棚子，我们得去棚子里。好吧，行吧。让他们脚踏实地。好吧，不管怎样。听听看。我想让你知道。
Love the dishwasher. I want to tell you, it was a f***ing show. F***. When I opened the dishwasher, I was like, what the hell happened in here? Everything was just thrown in there. I do remember the moments with my kids and when they were pretty old. And I'm like, could you just sweep this up and, you know, and then, you know,
装洗碗机。我想告诉你，那简直是一场灾难。见鬼。当我打开洗碗机时，我心想，这里面到底发生了什么鬼事？所有东西都是乱七八糟塞进去的。我确实记得和我的孩子们的那些时刻，当他们已经挺大的时候。我心想，你们能把这个扫一下吗，然后，你知道的，
and I started watching. I'm not even gonna name which one because pretty much all of them had this moment where I was watching them sweep. And I'm like, who taught you to sweep? What is that? Where'd you learn that? And I realized I've failed. I haven't taught them. It's my fault. I mean, I can't blame them for not knowing how to sweep.
然后，你知道的，我开始看着。我甚至不会说具体是哪一个，因为几乎所有人都有过这样的时刻：我看着他们扫地。然后我想，谁教你这么扫地的？那是什么？你在哪儿学到这招的？然后我意识到我失败了。我根本没教过他们。这是我的错。我的意思是，我不能怪他们不知道怎么扫地。
Clearly that's something you have to kind of, at some point. Someone has to show you. Oh my God, it was so embarrassing. I was like, that's not how you sweep. How is that? I thought that was just something you knew. No, no, it was so embarrassing. I was like, that's not how you sweep. How is that? I thought that was just something you knew. No, no, it's not natural.
显然这是一种你必须，在某个时刻。必须得有人教你。哦天哪，太尴尬了。我当时就想，根本不是这么扫地的。怎么会这样？我以为这是那种你生来就知道的事。不，不，这根本不是天生的。
I have a new thing that I just implemented with my kids. I wanna get your take on it, all right? Let's hear it. So I heard this on a podcast, which when I told my kids that they were like, oh no, mom heard a podcast. Mom and her podcast. CB. Mom and her podcast.
我最近刚在我的孩子们身上推行了一个新方法。我想听听你的看法，好吗？说来听听。所以我是在一个播客上听到这个的，当我把这事告诉我的孩子们时，他们就说，哦不，妈妈又听播客了。妈妈和她的播客。
KS. Mom and her ideas. So the thought behind it is rather than make them a chore list that they have to do, you teach them how to notice what needs to be done and do it because the mental labor of making the list and saying what has to be done, like that's half the chore. So what you're wanting to do is like raise people who can see with their own eyes what needs to be done. So I have this thing where I- This is a podcast called Pipe Dreams. Pipe Dreams for Parents. Pipe Dreams for Parents.
妈妈和她的那些点子。所以背后的想法是，与其给他们列一张必须完成的家务清单，不如教他们如何去注意有什么需要做的事，并主动去做，因为制作清单并说明必须做什么这种精神劳动，本身就占了一半的家务。所以你想做的是培养那些能用自己的眼睛看出有什么需要做的事情的人。所以我有个这样的方法——这是一个叫“白日梦”的播客吗？家长的白日梦。
Pipe Dream for Parents. Next on the Office Ladies Network. There's Pipe Dreams for Parents who don't live practically. So here's what I did. This is kind of thing. It feels like this is like right next to Whole Foods, like where you go down the aisle in Whole Foods and there's like just stuff in there that's supposed to do things. We're like, how is that even possible?
家长的白日梦。办公室女士网台的下一个节目。专为生活不够接地气的家长准备的白日梦。所以我做了这个。这就是那种东西。感觉这就好像全食超市（Whole Foods）里的那种东西，你走过全食超市的过道，货架上摆着各种号称能搞定一切的小玩意儿。我们当时就想，这怎么可能？
That doesn't work. We all just lost our minds as soon as we walked in this place. I set a timer for 15 minutes. And they have to notice? For 15 minutes, they have to walk around and notice, see what needs to be done and do it. How's that working? Wait, and then they're done after 15 minutes? Yeah. This is making my dishwasher thing look hardcore. I gotta say,
这根本不管用。我们一走进这地方脑子就全瓦特了。我设定了一个15分钟的定时器。他们必须去注意？他们必须花15分钟走来走去，去注意观察，看看有什么需要做的事然后把它做完。效果怎么样？等等，然后15分钟一到他们就完成了？对。这把我的洗碗机惩罚衬托得像个硬核特训了。我得说，
I mean, I hope they turn out. I do. You know that. And by the way, I feel the same about my kids are already in their 20s, so I have a pretty good idea. But that seems crazy compared to how... No, I mean, I'm not saying what my... Because because you know, I got, I think there's some areas they kind of screwed up, but they just said like, this is what needs to be done. That's hilarious. 15 minutes walk around, notice, I mean, the gag there is they take 12, 13 minutes to notice something.
我是说，我希望他们能成才。我是认真的。你知道的。顺便说一句，我对我的孩子们也有同感，他们都已经20多岁了，所以我心里挺有数的。但相比之下，这听起来太疯狂了……不，我的意思是，我不是在说我的……因为你知道的，我觉得他们在某些方面确实有点搞砸了，但他们只是说，这就是需要做的事。太搞笑了。15分钟走来走去，去注意观察，我的意思是，这里的笑点是他们花了12、13分钟才注意到某件事。
And then they're like, they only got two minutes to do it. Like, got it. Still looking around, Still looking around. Still looking around. I got 15. I've noticed a couple of things but I wanna keep kind of poking, there might be something better.
然后他们就发现，只剩下两分钟去干活了。就像，懂了。还在到处看，还在到处看。还在到处看。我有15分钟呢。我注意到几件事了，但我还想继续到处戳戳，可能还有更好的。
It's amazing. All right. I thought we got, I think we hit our stride somewhere where we realized if we just wrote the routines, that was the easiest way. Like write it on the board, your sort of tasks? Is what you're doing Monday, is what you're doing Tuesday, is what you're doing Wednesday.
这太神奇了。好吧。我想我们找到了节奏，就是在我们意识到如果我们直接写下日常安排，那才是最简单的方法。比如把你的各种任务写在黑板上？这就是你周一要做的，这就是你周二要做的，这就是你周三要做的。
Just these are the tasks. A little bit. Because otherwise you were constantly saying, you know, hey, I need you to, could you just go do this? Could you go? And they're like, oh my God, you're just going to throw that on me whenever. So it was more like, read the board. Here's the board.
这些就是任务。差不多吧。因为否则你就会不停地说，你知道的，嘿，我需要你，你能去把这个干了吗？你能去吗？然后他们就会说，哦天哪，你这是随时随地就把活儿甩给我了。所以这更像是，看黑板。黑板在这。
These are the things that are gonna be done. This is, you know, this is yours. This is your sister's. This is whatever. Yeah. And it is LA, it's not Modesto life. So it's not like they're out mowing, I mean. No.
这些就是需要完成的事。这是，你知道的，这是你的。这是你姐姐的。这是别的什么。对。而且这里是洛杉矶，不是莫德斯托的生活。所以他们可不是出去割草，我是说。没有。
No, we were like, we had like chores. I pulled weeds. I picked up dog poop. Oh yeah. You know? Yeah. I mean, I cleaned the toilets, I was bathrooms. That was my job in my house growing up. Oh, that's cool.
没有，我们以前，我们有很多家务。我拔过草。我清理过狗屎。哦，对。你知道吗？对。我的意思是，我擦过马桶，我打扫过浴室。那是我小时候在家里分到的活儿。哦，那挺酷。
Yeah. I think just three boys and we were just out in the yard working. We had daily chores and then weekends were like yeah all hands on my memory is a few hours before I was free to go hang out yeah it was always my buddies making plans and then they're like you'll join us like around noon one o'clock when you're done I'm going over the canal to open up to water you'd have to let the water into the field and water the fields and... Those are real chores.
对。我觉得家里就三个男孩，我们就是一直在院子里干活。我们有日常家务，然后周末就像是，对，全员出动。我的记忆是，在我有空出去玩之前的几个小时，对，总是我的死党们在做计划，然后他们会说，你大概在中午一点钟做完的时候加入我们。我得去运河边放水，把水引到田里去浇地……那才是真正的家务。
We had real chores, yeah. Did you take 15 minutes to look around? 15 minutes, just take 15 minutes to look around. Just see what needed to be done. I think in theory this is a really good thing though. It's amazing. All right, our final question. Then we're gonna let you go.
我们以前有真正的家务，对。你们花15分钟到处看吗？15分钟，只要花15分钟到处看看。看看有什么需要做的。不过我觉得从理论上讲，这真的是个好主意。太棒了。好的，我们的最后一个问题。然后我们就放你走。
What is your favorite midnight snack? Oh, I'm gonna go with, I guess I would go with like peanut butter, oh yeah, lately probably peanut butter. Like peanut butter, if there's like a- Just straight up with a spoon? God, we have gotten to this place where we don't have a lot of, like back in the day I'd be like ice cream, but now I'm like,
你最喜欢的午夜零食是什么？哦，我会选，我想我会选花生酱，哦对，最近大概是花生酱。就像花生酱，如果有一个——直接拿勺子挖着吃？天哪，我们现在已经落到这种地步了，家里没那么多，以前我可能会吃冰淇淋，但现在我觉得，
I don't really do that anymore. Like, isn't that sad? You get to a certain age, you have memories of midnight snacks. Yeah. Yeah. I remember I used to eat a pint of ice cream. Now I was like, what?
我真的不怎么吃那个了。难道不觉得很悲哀吗？等你到了某个年纪，你对午夜零食的记忆就只剩回忆了。对。对。我记得我以前会吃掉一品脱冰淇淋。现在我心想，什么？
That's gross, disgusting. What's wrong with you? You gotta get up and swim. Exactly. So now like we don't, like, if I think like right now at the house, the only thing that we have that I will definitely reach for is I bought a bunch of, I was in Finland working. I brought so much good licorice home. So I like reached for the licorice. But when that's gone, I'm, that's it. I'm screwed. I'm just like, oh, maybe some peanut butter and honey.
这也太恶心、太低级了吧。你脑子有病吧？你还得早起去游泳呢。没错。所以现在我们不，如果我觉得现在家里唯一有的、我肯定会去拿的东西是我买了一堆，我当时在芬兰工作。我带了超多好吃的甘草糖回家。所以我经常会去拿甘草糖。但当那个吃完了，我就，那就完了。我彻底没戏了。我只会想，哦，也许来点花生酱配蜂蜜。
I mean, really my midnight snack is probably just like bourbon. That's my midnight snack. It's just the, it's just the liquor cabinet. The bourbon on the rocks. Yeah, exactly. There you go. Thank you so much. This was a pleasure.
我的意思是，实际上我的午夜零食可能就是波旁威士忌。那才是我的午夜零食。就是那个，就是酒柜里的酒。加冰的波旁威士忌。对，没错。就是这样。非常感谢。太荣幸了。
Ladies, if I can call you that. You can. You can call us ladies. Ladies, it's been a pleasure. Thank you so much. Thanks for having me. Well, we're gonna get your dates that you can travel. So when we go on the road. Exactly. Yeah, all right a pleasure. Thank you so much. Thanks for having me. Well, we're gonna get your dates that you can travel. So when we go on the road.
女士们，如果我能这么称呼你们的话。你可以。你可以叫我们女士。女士们，这真是一段美好的时光。非常感谢。谢谢你们邀请我。好吧，我们会拿到你可以旅行的日期。所以当我们去公路旅行的时候。没错。对，好的，太荣幸了。非常感谢。谢谢你们邀请我。好吧，我们会拿到你可以旅行的日期。所以当我们去公路旅行的时候。
Yeah, all right. Awesome. Thank you. Thank you, Timothy. It was my pleasure. I mean, how fun. He is so funny. I know.
对，好的。太棒了。谢谢。谢谢你，蒂莫西。这是我的荣幸。我的意思是，多有趣啊。他太搞笑了。我知道。
And Angie, you actually ended up going to his tennis charity event. I did. You know, after the interview we were talking a little bit before he left and he was like I'm serious. If you want to play you should come. He got my phone number and on my drive home he called me and he was like hey I'm about to text you all the info. I was like okay. It was the next day and lady I wore my Songs of Scranton t-shirt to represent
安吉，你后来居然真的去了他的网球慈善活动。我去了。你知道，采访结束后，在他离开之前我们聊了一会儿，他说我是认真的。如果你想打球，你真该来。他记了我的电话号码，在开车回家的路上他给我打电话，说，嘿，我等下把所有信息发短信给你。我心想，好吧。那是第二天，女士，我穿着我的“斯克兰顿之歌”T恤去代表
the office ladies team. I was paired up with Timothy's sister-in-law Robin and I played with this great group of gals and I met a lot of his family. It was very much a family affair. Plus, there were some fantastic tennis players, like jaw-dropping, amazing tennis and some familiar faces like Joel McHale. Oh yes. Mm-hmm.
办公室女士队。我和蒂莫西的小姨子罗宾分到了一组，我和这群超级棒的姑娘们一起打球，我还见了他的很多家人。这真是一个地道的家庭聚会。另外，还有一些非常厉害的网球选手，简直是让人惊掉下巴的惊艳球技，还有一些熟悉的面孔，比如乔尔·麦克哈尔。哦，是的。嗯-hmm。
I just want you guys all to know that Joel has a really good cross-court forehand. Although, and Joel, I have given him crap about this. He did get schooled on the court one or two times. Oh, did he? Okay. But that's okay. There was, these tennis players were really good. I was not in the like super good.
我只想让你们大家知道，乔尔的斜线正手球打得真的很好。不过，而且乔尔，我为此开过他玩笑。他在球场上确实被虐了一两次。哦，是吗？好吧。不过没关系。那些网球选手真的很厉害。我可不在那种超级厉害的水平。
I was in like the medium court. Is that what they call it? Super good, medium good, not so court. Is that what they call it? Super good, medium good, not so good? Is that how they come across it? That is not how they did. They had, if you want to know, they had like 4.5s and 4s and 3.5s and I was on the 3.5 court. Okay. And 3s, but I was, yeah. So I was, 3.5 is good, lady.
我当时大概在中级球场。是这么叫的吗？超级好、中等好、不太好。是这么叫的吗？超级好、中等好、不太好？他们是这么分类的吗？他们可不是这样的。如果你想知道的话，他们有4.5级、4级和3.5级，而我在3.5级的球场。好吧。还有3级，但我当时，是的。所以我是，3.5级已经很不错了，女士。
That was my GPA in college. Oh, well that's very good. So it served me well there. But it was a really fun day, and thank you, Timothy, for including me and Robin for introducing me to your tennis gals. And you know, it was just a lot of great people coming together for a good cause. I will share in our stories, but like Timothy said in his interview, all the proceeds went to Center for Reflective Communities, and I'll put a swipe up so you can learn more
那是我大学时的GPA。哦，那挺好的。所以它在那儿对我也很有用。但这真是非常开心的一天，谢谢蒂姆把我加入进去，也谢谢罗宾把我介绍给你们的网球闺蜜们。你知道的，这就像是一群很棒的人聚在一起做一件好事。我会在我们的快拍里分享，但正如蒂姆在采访中所说的那样，所有的收益都捐给了反思社区中心，我会放一个上滑链接，这样你们可以了解更多
about it. Well, Angela, another follow-up that we should give is that Timothy did go and see Rain's production, the closing night of Waiting for Godot, and loved it. Loved it. Took his mom. Texted us to update us, which I thought was so nice. Hey, ladies, by the way, we loved it. Loved the play.
关于它的信息。安吉拉，我们要给大家的另一个后续是，蒂姆确实去看了雷恩的作品，也就是《等待戈多》的闭幕之夜演出，并且非常喜欢。非常喜欢。还带着他妈妈一起去的。给我们发短信随时同步进展，我觉得这太贴心了。嘿，女士们，顺便说一句，我们太喜欢了。非常喜欢这部话剧。
Well, a big thank you to Timothy for coming in the studio to talk with us. We hope you enjoyed this episode and thank you to everyone who sent in questions. We just love hearing from you. Have a great week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela
非常感谢蒂姆来到录音室与我们聊天。希望你们喜欢这期节目，也谢谢所有发来问题的朋友。我们特别喜欢听到你们的反馈。祝大家度过美好的一周。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉
Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
金斯饰演制作人。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制作人是艾恩斯莉·布比科。Audyssey的执行制作人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。